Hello and welcome to your second drink of the job part one. Paul Lieberstein joined us for the top of this episode. You know, he wrote this episode along with Mike Scher. What a dynamic duo. Right. This was a great interview. We got to hear all about how he came to play Toby. Yeah, and he gave some really fun facts about this episode as well.
你好，欢迎收听《办公室》第二季的第二杯酒，第一部分。保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）在本集开头加入了我们。你知道，这一集是他和迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）一起写的。真是个充满活力的二人组，对吧。这是一次很棒的采访。我们听到了他当初是如何获得托比（Toby）这个角色的。是的，他还分享了一些关于这一集的非常有趣的幕后事实。
So the job part one ran as a special hour-long season three finale episode along with the job part two. But, you know, it was actually only 40 minutes with commercials. Well, the superfan episode for the Job 1 and 2 is over an hour long, a real hour, no commercials. That's like a mini The Office movie. Yes, it's almost like they added a third episode. And there is a very big thing that was added back to the cold open. We kind of talked about it in our breakdown.
《工作》第一部分是作为第三季一小时长的特别季终集播出的，与《工作》第二部分一起。但实际上，算上广告它只有40分钟。嗯，超级粉丝版《工作》1和2加起来超过一个小时，是实打实的一小时，没有广告。那就像一部《办公室》迷你电影。是的，感觉就像他们增加了一集。而且冷开场里加回了一个非常重要的内容。我们在解析中提到过。
You know, in the job part two, when Jim is being interviewed by, David Wallace, and there's a little flashback to the beach games episode. And Jim tells Pam why he left Scranton. To go to Stanford. Yes. Yeah. Well, when we first discussed this episode, we talked about that flashback scene at the beach for Jim and Pam, and we said that it was originally going to be the cold open for this episode. Well, we got it a little wrong, lady. It can happen. So give me the scoop. Well, the scene during Jim's interview was always meant to be there. There was a different part of that scene on the beach between Jim and Pam that would have been the cold open. And I didn't realize that when we first broke down the episode, they have put that cold open back into the superfan
你知道，在《工作》第二部分里，当吉姆（Jim）接受大卫·华莱士（David Wallace）面试时，有一个关于《海滩游戏》那一集的小闪回。吉姆告诉帕姆（Pam）他为什么要离开斯克兰顿（Scranton）去斯坦福（Stanford）。是的。嗯，当我们第一次讨论这一集时，我们谈到了吉姆和帕姆在海滩上的那个闪回场景，我们说它原本应该是这一集的冷开场。嗯，我们搞错了一点，女士。这很正常。那给我讲讲内幕吧。嗯，吉姆面试时的那个场景一直都在那里。海滩上吉姆和帕姆之间还有另一段场景，那本来应该是冷开场。我第一次解析这一集时没意识到，他们把那个冷开场加回了超级粉丝版里。
episode. It totally kicks off Pam's like new direct way of communicating. You have to hear it. Hey, I'm really sorry that I didn't come to your art show. Okay. Is that all you heard? Because I said some other stuff. Really? I don't... I don't... You know what's interesting? I don't feel embarrassed at all. I just feel good. Good. If you don't have anything to say, you don't have to say anything.
这一集完全开启了帕姆那种新的直接沟通方式。你一定要听听。嘿，我很抱歉我没去参加你的艺术展。好吧。你只听到了这些吗？因为我还说了别的话。真的吗？我不……我不……你知道什么很有趣吗？我一点也不觉得尴尬。我只觉得很好。很好。如果你没什么可说的，你就不必说什么。
No, I take that back. You have to say something. Hey! You guys, I'm doing it. I'm walking on boiling steam. How can you even think about leaving that? Hey, can anybody see this? I mean, does he just sit there silent the whole time? Yeah.
不，我收回前言。你必须说点什么。嘿！你们，我在做了。我在沸腾的蒸汽上行走。你怎么能想到离开那个？嘿，有人能看到这个吗？我的意思是，他整个过程就一直沉默地坐在那里吗？是的。
I really liked how she was like, is that all you're going to respond to? Because I said some other stuff. Yeah, she does not let him off the hook. Go, Pam. So I traded messages with Dave Rogers about these flashbacks, and he said that this is one of his single favorite moments of the show because it's one of those rare things where even the way it was in the original broadcast really illuminated the creative freedom that the documentary filmmakers have
我真的很喜欢她说“你只会回应这个吗？因为我还说了别的话”。是的，她没有让他轻易脱身。加油，帕姆。所以我跟戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）交流了关于这些闪回的内容，他说这是他个人最喜欢的剧集瞬间之一，因为这是极少数即使在原始播出版本中，也能体现纪录片制作人在决定展示什么以及何时展示时所拥有的创作自由的时刻。
when they are deciding what they want to show and when. Sure. I mean, they can tell a completely different version of a moment through editing. And that's true even when you watch reality TV today. Yes. He said that they talked a lot about this in the edit that they decided to use. like the portion of this flashback footage that they decided to use in the job part two. They really tried to put themselves in the mindset of the documentary crew.
当然。我的意思是，他们可以通过剪辑讲述一个完全不同版本的瞬间。即使在今天观看真人秀时也是如此。是的。他说他们在剪辑时讨论了很多关于他们决定使用的内容。比如他们在《工作》第二部分中决定使用的那部分闪回镜头。他们真的试图让自己进入纪录片摄制组的心态。
Originally, they settled on just having the one little clip. Also in the episode, when Pam has her talking head at the top of this episode, you see just sort of like a flashback to this conversation with no audio. And Pam just says, Jim was nice, told me that he missed our friendship too, and then they kind of hug and walk off. And then Dave said again, when they had this bigger chunk of the scene, they had to discuss again, like, where would the documentary crew put this? Where would it make the most sense to put this?
最初，他们决定只保留那一个小片段。同样在这一集中，当帕姆在这一集开头进行访谈时，你会看到一段没有声音的关于这次谈话的闪回。帕姆只是说，吉姆人很好，告诉我他也怀念我们的友谊，然后他们拥抱并走开了。戴夫又说，当他们有这段更长的场景时，他们不得不再次讨论，纪录片摄制组会把这个放在哪里？放在哪里最合理？
And they decided to put it back up at the top. I just love Dave's insight on everything. I know, lady. I wrote him an email about it where I said, oh, can you tell me about these flashback scenes to Beach Games? And the beginning of his email was, get ready for a Dave Rogers dissertation or just give me a call. Well, I also wanted to share a scene that was added back to the superfan episode.
他们决定把它放回开头。我真的很喜欢戴夫对一切的见解。我知道，女士。我给他写了一封邮件，我说，哦，你能告诉我关于这些《海滩游戏》的闪回场景吗？他邮件的开头是，准备好迎接戴夫·罗杰斯的论文吧，或者直接给我打电话。嗯，我还想分享一个加回超级粉丝版的场景。
I had mentioned it in our breakdown. It's the runner of Dwight interviewing Andy. Yes. So the stuff that was included in the episode is so funny. And I mentioned that there was a lot more in the deleted scenes. We didn't play it before. And I just thought it would be so fun to hear it. So here are the extra interview questions that got added back to the superfan episode.
我在我们的解析中提到过。就是德怀特（Dwight）面试安迪（Andy）的那个桥段。是的。所以包含在剧集里的内容太搞笑了。我提到删除的片段里还有很多。我们之前没放出来。我只是觉得听听这些内容会很有趣。所以这里是加回超级粉丝版的额外面试问题。
What is 879 times 413.7, 2,401.6.6. Four, seven, repeating. Inventor of the cotton gin. Eli Edison. When is the Paleolithic age? 17 BC. Who's the second man on the moon? Trick question.
879乘以413.7等于多少？2401.6.6。四，七，循环。轧棉机的发明者是谁？伊莱·爱迪生（Eli Edison）。旧石器时代是什么时候？公元前17年。谁是第二个登上月球的人？陷阱题。
There was no second man on the moon. Talk me through an appendectomy. Step one, disinfection. Step two, incision. Step three, remove the appendix tenderly so it doesn't burst and spread toxicicity everywhere. Step four, the ectomy procedure. Step five. Resedger.
没有第二个登上月球的人。给我讲讲阑尾切除术。第一步，消毒。第二步，切开。第三步，温柔地取出阑尾，以免它破裂并将毒素扩散到各处。第四步，切除手术。第五步。缝合。
Soutures. Soutures, yes. What is the origin of species? How far away is Venus? Define scorched earth policy. How do you please a woman? What is a scented candle? What is the Dharma initiative?
缝合，是的。物种起源是什么？金星离我们有多远？定义焦土政策。如何取悦女性？什么是香薰蜡烛？什么是达摩计划（Dharma Initiative）？
It is the source of all energy on this planet. It is a corporation formed by aliens. You just know our writers had so much fun. I mean, especially that little section of where you're just hearing the questions. I mean, I know that was like on the day pitches. Oh, yeah. I don't know how rain got through that. I'm sure he didn't.
它是这个星球上所有能量的来源。它是一家由外星人组成的公司。你就是知道我们的编剧玩得很开心。我的意思是，尤其是当你听到那些问题的部分。我知道那是在当天的头脑风暴中产生的。哦，是的。我不知道雷恩（Rainn）是怎么忍住的。我肯定他没忍住。
I'm sure there's footage of him cracking up. Well, finally, Angela, we talked a lot about the Jim, Pam, Karen relationship in this episode. Yeah. And we got a letter from Lindsay C, who said, if there is ever a second drink episode of the job, I just wanted to throw out another possible point of view of Jim's reactions to Karen in this episode. I feel like Jim has never been fully 100% committed to this relationship and was often put out with Karen and maybe even looking for ways to brush her off. For example, right before Roy's attack, Karen is talking to him about how he'd rather stay home and watch a Phillies game than go out with
我肯定有他笑场的镜头。好吧，最后，安吉拉（Angela），我们在这一集里谈了很多关于吉姆、帕姆和凯伦（Karen）的关系。是的。我们收到了一封来自琳赛·C（Lindsay C）的信，她说，如果以后还有《工作》的第二杯酒节目，我想提出另一个关于吉姆在这一集中对凯伦反应的视角。我觉得吉姆从来没有百分之百地投入到这段关系中，而且经常对凯伦感到厌烦，甚至可能在寻找摆脱她的方法。例如，在罗伊（Roy）袭击之前，凯伦正在和他谈论他宁愿待在家里看费城人队的比赛，也不愿和她出去。
her. Like you've both said before, we all love Jim, of course, but a lot of times throughout this relationship, it really does bring out his worst. So when Jim had the talking head explaining his haircut and Karen's snarky comment about him looking homeless, I think he was truly offended by it and holding on to a bit of a grudge. Then, when in New York, instead of giving Karen any kind of answer about moving with her or about one too many people in New York, I think it's because he is truly conflicted. He is on this trip trying to enjoy their relationship, but having to really search for the happiness that it should be providing. So then when he finds the beloved yogurt lid and Karen has just ditched him for her girlfriends, I think it was a real
就像你们之前说的那样，我们都爱吉姆，当然，但在整个关系中，这确实暴露了他最糟糕的一面。所以当吉姆在访谈中解释他的发型，而凯伦刻薄地评论他看起来像个流浪汉时，我认为他真的被冒犯了，并且怀恨在心。然后，在纽约，他没有给凯伦任何关于和她一起搬家或者关于纽约人太多了的回答，我认为是因为他真的很矛盾。他这次旅行试图享受他们的关系，但不得不真正去寻找它本应提供的快乐。所以当他找到那个心爱的酸奶盖，而凯伦为了她的女朋友们抛弃了他时，我认为这对他来说是一个真正的顿悟时刻。
aha moment for him. Huh. Mm-hmm. I mean, I can see the aha moment. I rewatched this whole episode. And there are so many glaring examples of Jim and Karen not being in sync. And I also felt like Karen was like a really cool woman, but not the right woman for Jim. Like he didn't see her. She was cool. She was making jokes. They don't want to do the same things. They are just like, they are not a match. It was so clear to me when I rewatched this episode. Because she's a catch. She's a total catch. She's not his person. No, he's not like charmed by her the way he should be. Well, there's like that thing, you know, where it's like when you're really into someone, the littlest thing they do you think is charming.
哈。嗯。我的意思是，我能看出那个顿悟时刻。我重看了整集。吉姆和凯伦不同步的例子太明显了。我也觉得凯伦是个很酷的女人，但不是适合吉姆的女人。他没看懂她。她很酷。她会开玩笑。他们不想做同样的事情。他们就是不合适。当我重看这一集时，这对我来说太清楚了。因为她是个好姑娘。她绝对是个好姑娘。她不是他的那个人。不，他并没有像他应该的那样被她吸引。嗯，你知道有那种事，就是当你真的很喜欢某人时，他们做的最小的事情你都会觉得很迷人。
And someone else who likes you and you're not into can do the same thing. And you're like, oh, totally. He sent me flowers. Ugh, why? Yes, he's driving me crazy like flowers every week. And then like, if you like them, you're like, oh, my gosh, he sends me flowers every week. Yeah. It's just not your person.
而另一个喜欢你但你不喜欢的人做同样的事情，你会觉得，哦，完全是。他给我送了花。呃，为什么？是的，他每周送花让我快疯了。然后，如果你喜欢他们，你会觉得，哦，天哪，他每周都给我送花。是的。那只是不是你的那个人。
All right, everyone. That's all we got. Don't forget to grab a copy of Josh and Angela's cookbook. You can make this. It comes out tomorrow. Yay! Thank you. Also tomorrow, be sure to tune in and catch them on the Today Show. Yes, we are doing a bunch of fun stuff.
好了，各位。这就是我们所有的内容了。别忘了买一本乔什（Josh）和安吉拉的食谱。你可以做这个。明天就上市了。耶！谢谢。明天也一定要收看《今日秀》（Today Show）。是的，我们要去做很多有趣的事情。
We'll also be on the show Sherry, hosted by Sherry Shepard, and we kick off our book tour. Josh is also joining us on Wednesday on Office Ladies 6.0. He's part of our top of show because, you know, it's the food episode. We're going to talk all things food on the set of the office. We sure are. And don't forget everyone. The podcast, How We Made Your Mother, is premiering on the Office Ladies Network today. Yes. All right. Now, please enjoy your second drink of the job part one.
我们还会参加雪莉·谢泼德（Sherry Shepherd）主持的《雪莉》节目，并开启我们的新书巡回宣传。乔什周三也会加入我们的《办公室女士》6.0。他是我们节目开头的一部分，因为，你知道，这是美食集。我们要谈谈《办公室》片场关于食物的一切。我们当然会。别忘了，各位。播客《我们是如何认识你母亲的》（How We Made Your Mother）今天在《办公室女士》网络首播。是的。好了。现在，请享受你的《工作》第一部分第二杯酒。
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell. you. We're the office ladies. Hey there, everyone. It's Angela Kinsey. It's Jenna Fisher. And we are here to talk to you this week about the job. Yes. It's the end of season three, Angela. This is the season three finale. I can't believe we're already at the season three finale. I can't either. I can't either. I was saying to my husband the other day, I was like, babe, Jen and I have talked for a year now about the show. And it doesn't even feel like any time has gone by. I mean, I think we just really enjoy
我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）。我是安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并分享只有两个亲历者才能讲述的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。嘿，大家好。我是安吉拉·金赛。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我们这周在这里和你们谈谈《工作》。是的。这是第三季的结尾，安吉拉。这是第三季的季终集。我不敢相信我们已经到了第三季的季终集了。我也不敢相信。我也不敢相信。前几天我还在跟我丈夫说，我说，亲爱的，珍和我已经谈了一年关于这部剧了。感觉好像时间还没过去多久。我的意思是，我觉得我们真的很享受
hanging out and talking with each other and also talking about the show. Well, this is actually the job part one. This is an hour-long episode finale. So we're dividing it into two episodes of Office Ladies so that we can really cover everything. This was written by Paul Lieberstein and Mike Shore and directed by Ken Quapis. Jenna, do you know it was all co-edited, not only co-written, but it was co-edited with Dave Rogers and Dean Holland. Wow. Because it was such a big episode. We put everyone on this.
在一起聊天，也谈论这部剧。嗯，这实际上是《工作》第一部分。这是一个一小时长的季终集。所以我们把它分成两集《办公室女士》，这样我们就能真正涵盖所有内容。这一集由保罗·利伯斯坦和迈克·舒尔编写，肯·夸皮斯（Ken Kwapis）执导。珍娜，你知道它是共同剪辑的吗？不仅是共同编写，还由戴夫·罗杰斯和迪恩·霍兰德（Dean Holland）共同剪辑。哇。因为这是一集大制作。我们把所有人都投入进去了。
All hands on deck. Well, here is a summary for part one. Before leaving for his interview and confident he already has a new job at corporate, Michael names Dwight as his replacement at Dunder-Mifflin Scranton. Angela could not be more excited. Oh, yeah. But before Michael can leave, Jan pays a surprise visit. She shows Michael her new breast enhancement and says she wants to get back together.
全员出动。嗯，这是第一部分的摘要。在去面试之前，迈克尔（Michael）确信自己已经在总公司得到了一份新工作，于是任命德怀特为他在邓德尔-米夫林（Dunder-Mifflin）斯克兰顿分公司的接班人。安吉拉再兴奋不过了。哦，是的。但在迈克尔离开之前，简（Jan）突然造访。她向迈克尔展示了她的新隆胸，并说她想复合。
Jim and Karen leave early as they are also interviewing for the job at corporate. Dwight makes Andy his number two since Andy is the only person who would interview for the position. And that's just the first half. There's more to come. Yeah. Well, listen, to kick off this. finale episode, we have a surprise guest. We're so excited. Writer, Toby himself, Paul Lieberstein. Toby is in the house. Well, you know, in the Zoom house. Toby's in the Zoom house.
吉姆和凯伦提前离开，因为他们也要去总公司面试那份工作。德怀特让安迪当他的二把手，因为安迪是唯一一个愿意面试这个职位的人。这还只是前半部分。后面还有更多。是的。嗯，听着，为了开启这一季终集，我们有一位惊喜嘉宾。我们太兴奋了。编剧，托比本人，保罗·利伯斯坦。托比在现场。嗯，你知道，在Zoom现场。托比在Zoom现场。
Oh, well, we asked him all about being Toby and all about this episode. Sam, will you play the interview? Hello, Paul Lieberstein. Welcome to office ladies. Hello, Jennifer. Hello, Angel Kinsey. Thank you for having me. Oh, thanks so much for being on. My pleasure.
哦，嗯，我们问了他所有关于扮演托比以及关于这一集的问题。萨姆（Sam），你能播放采访吗？你好，保罗·利伯斯坦。欢迎来到《办公室女士》。你好，珍妮弗。你好，安吉拉·金赛。谢谢你们邀请我。哦，非常感谢你能来。我的荣幸。
We're so excited to have you today. Thank you. I'm excited to be here. Good. We were texting, and I know you were texting with Angela as well, and you told us that you have not seen an episode of the show, since it aired, but that you were going to watch the job today,
我们今天很高兴你能来。谢谢。我很高兴能来这里。很好。我们发了短信，我知道你也和安吉拉发了短信，你告诉我们你自从播出以来就没看过一集这部剧，但你今天打算看《工作》，
how was that experience for you? I'm dying to know. It was really interesting. I felt like there's moments that really, really shined. And then there's like, you know, the writer part of me and it's like, oh, okay, I think I would have done that a little differently now. But I didn't think there was anything that was, like, embarrassing. No.
那对你来说是什么样的体验？我太想知道了。这真的很有趣。我觉得有些时刻真的很闪光。然后，你知道，作为编剧的那部分我在想，哦，好吧，我想我现在会做得有点不同。但我认为没有什么让我觉得尴尬的。不。
You are so hard on yourself. This is an amazing, delightful episode. I know you, and you're such an amazing writer, and I can see you watching things through the filter of like, oh, and you're a producer, and you direct. So I imagine you're watching it through all those different layers. Yeah. Yeah, no, no, there's everything.
你对自己太苛刻了。这是一集令人惊叹、令人愉快的剧集。我了解你，你是一位如此出色的编剧，我能看出你是通过一种滤镜在看东西，比如，哦，而且你还是制片人，你还执导。所以我猜你是通过所有这些不同的层面在看它。是的。是的，不，不，什么都有。
It's like framing. It's like, oh, I should be a fun of, oh. Or that was repetitive. We already said that. Paul. We didn't need to do it again. But then I get really impressed with some other stuff. Well, we do always like to start by asking people how they came to be on the office.
就像构图。就像，哦，我应该是一个粉丝，哦。或者那太重复了。我们已经说过了。保罗。我们不需要再做一次。但后来我对其他一些东西印象深刻。嗯，我们总是喜欢先问人们他们是如何来到《办公室》的。
You are one of our original writers and you were with us the entire nine seasons. You were our showrunner as well for a period of time. How did it come about that you were on the show? Well, I had worked with Greg Daniels before and known him a very long time. And we did King in the Hill together. And when they started the show, I, you know, I stopped by the pilot. You know, I had nothing to do with the pilot, but I stopped by a few days. And it was, I just kind of loved what was happening.
你是我们最初的编剧之一，你和我们一起度过了整整九季。你在一段时间内也是我们的剧集主管。你是怎么来到这部剧的？嗯，我之前和格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）合作过，认识他很久了。我们一起做过《山丘之王》（King of the Hill）。当他们开始这部剧时，我，你知道，我在试播集时顺便去看了看。你知道，我跟试播集没什么关系，但我顺便去了几天。我只是有点喜欢正在发生的事情。
And it was, you know, I loved the British. And so then when it got picked up, I was psyched that he asked me to come on. So there's just like kind of a very traditional thing that writers and actors are kind of separating on a TV show. you know and they're kind of asked not to talk and he at this point was questioning a lot of those like rules and why was this happening and just is this really make a better TV show so we talked about roles for it was Mindy and BJ and myself and Mike and then there was a couple of consultants there's Lester and Larry so the four of us each got like little roles I guess Mike's didn't come on.
而且，你知道，我喜欢英版。所以当它被预订时，我很兴奋他邀请我加入。所以这就像是一种非常传统的做法，编剧和演员在电视节目中是分开的。你知道，他们被要求不要说话，而他在这一点上质疑了很多这样的规则，为什么会这样，这真的能做出更好的电视节目吗？所以我们讨论了角色，有明迪（Mindy）、BJ（BJ Novak）和我自己，还有迈克，然后还有几个顾问，莱斯特（Lester）和拉里（Larry）。所以我们四个人每个人都得到了一些小角色，我想迈克没来。
Most didn't start that season. But so we talked about just doing a little thing to kind of have the experience of being an actor and hopefully it would inform our writing. So here he wanted to kind of like break that down together. So I feel like I'm not sure how to we happen, but I feel like I left the room and I came back and they said, you're going to you're going to play this part. and it was one line, you know, in Diversity Day about, you know, I say this one line and get kicked out of the room. Now, I heard Paul, and you tell me if this is true, I heard that at the table read, they had you read that line and that Steve as Michael jumped on you so viciously and everyone erupted in laughter because you sort of almost reacted and a little bit as yourself and a little bit maybe how you thought Toby might, you know, but you still didn't know who Toby was. at that moment, right? You're still discovering
大多数人那一季没开始。但我们讨论了只是做一点小事来体验一下当演员的感觉，希望这能为我们的写作提供参考。所以在这里他想一起打破这种隔阂。所以我感觉我不确定是怎么发生的，但我感觉我离开了房间，回来后他们说，你要扮演这个角色。那只有一句台词，你知道，在《多元化日》里，关于，你知道，我说这一句台词然后被赶出了房间。现在，我听说保罗，你告诉我这是不是真的，我听说在剧本朗读会上，他们让你读那句台词，史蒂夫（Steve）作为迈克尔恶狠狠地扑向你，每个人都爆发出笑声，因为你有点几乎是作为你自己做出了反应，有点可能像你认为托比可能会做的那样，你知道，但你当时还不知道托比是谁，对吧？你还在探索
who is Toby? There were early table reads where it was just for weird contractual reasons, just the main five actors. And I was reading Kevin. Yeah, you read a few roles. Yeah. And I think I did
谁是托比？早期有剧本朗读会，因为一些奇怪的合同原因，只有主要的五位演员。我在读凯文（Kevin）。是的，你读了几个角色。是的。我想我做得很好。我想我作为凯文得到了笑声。我想配角不在那里是因为你们是客串明星，不是系列常规演员。所以在系列常规合同中，你被要求参加剧本朗读会。这是你表演协议的一部分，但我想他们必须付给你更多钱。哦，参加那些？如果你没有那种合同的话。听起来是对的。是的，你知道，很有趣，因为我，
well. I think I got laughs as Kevin. I think that the supporting cast wasn't there because you were guest stars and you were not series regular. So in a series regular contract, you're required to do the table read. It's part of your acting deal, but I think they have to pay you more. Oh, to attend those? If you don't have that kind of contract. That sounds right. Yeah, you know, it's interesting because I,
作为客串明星，他们说你被邀请了。是的。对吧？不是必须的。如果你想来，你被邀请了。我总是去。但我认为你是对的，珍娜。直到《布的游轮》（Booze Cruise）之后我们才开始参加剧本朗读会。是的。所以保罗，你读了一堆角色，当迈克尔作为托比扑向你时，每个人都笑了。我觉得这有助于敲定这个角色。但我们也从没想过那个角色会再回来。哦，这就是他们抓住你的方式。这就是迈克·舒尔说的关于摩斯（Moes）的事。那本来应该只是一张愚蠢的照片，你知道。是的。是的。没错。你开始只是一张照片。然后几年后，他不得不留着那个胡子整整一年，整整一季，因为格雷格不让他用假的。而这一切开始是因为他只是要出现在一张
as a guest star, they say you're invited. Yeah. Right? Not required. You're invited if you would like to come. And I always do. But I think you're right, Jenna. It wasn't until after Boo's Cruise that we started coming to table reads. Yeah. So Paul, you read a bunch of roles and and everyone left when Michael jumped on you as Toby. And I feel like that helps seal the deal. But we also didn't expect that part to come back ever. Oh, that's how they got you. That's what Mike sure. That's what Mike said about Moes. It was just supposed to be a silly photo, you know. Yeah. Yeah. That's right. You started as a photo. And then years later, he had to walk around with that beard for like a whole year, a whole season, because Greg wouldn't let him use a fake one. And it all started because he was just going to be in a
照片里。然后我觉得假的看起来更好。是的，然后他很愤怒，因为他留了那么大的胡子，而假的也一样有效。嗯，保罗，那次体验怎么样？格雷格是对的吗？你觉得你从当演员的经历中学到了东西吗？我绝对学到了，但这花了一段时间才达到。我不知道你记不记得，但我们当时在做那种关于我的表演学校的房间段子。我记得你的表演学校。我记得你的表演学校。段子。好吧。所以想象一下在对表演一无所知的情况下进入表演。你被教的第一件事是把你的水瓶从桌子上拿下来放在桌子下面，因为标签没有被清理。好吧。那现在是我关于表演知道的第一件事。就像
photo. And then the fake one looked better, I think. Yes, and then he was furious because he had had that huge beard and the fake one worked just as well. Well, Paul, how was that experience? Was Greg right? Did you feel like you learned from the experience of being an actor? I absolutely did, but it took a while to get there. I don't know if you remember, but we were doing this kind of room bit about like my acting school. I do remember your acting school. I do remember your acting school. bit. Okay. So imagine going into acting knowing nothing about acting. And the first thing you're being taught is take your water bottle off your desk and put it underneath your desk because the label isn't cleared. All right. That's now the first thing I know about acting. And it was like
那样的事情构成了我的表演学校。我记得。另外，我记得雷恩会非常严厉地对待你。就像你说，嘿，凯特（Kate）。她说，嘿，保罗。然后你就像，该死。因为她本应该在场景中和你结婚。我记得雷恩会非常严厉地戏弄你。是的，我做的表演很少。对我来说有一个突破性的时刻。他们一直说，大声点。但我没有。
things like that that made up my acting school. I remember. Also, I remember Rain would just ride you so hard. Like you go, hey Kate. And she goes, hey Paul. And you're like, dang it. Because she was supposed to be married up in the moment you're in a scene. And I remember Rain would like tease you so hard. Yeah, there was very little acting I was doing. There was a breakthrough moment for me. They kept saying, talk louder. And I wouldn't.
你就像，不，我正在和这里的一个人说话。我为什么要大声点？你只是为自己推出了多机位，但没关系。是的，还有剧院。都在剧院里。然后我们正在做一个厨房场景，他们一直告诉我大声点。然后布莱恩（Brian）说，为什么你不想象这个房间是人为安静的，因为他们关掉了冰箱，对吧？
You're like, no, I'm talking to a person right here. Why would I talk louder? You just rolled out multi-cams for yourself, but that's okay. Yeah, and theater. All in theater. And then so we were doing a kitchen scene and they kept telling me to speak up. And then Brian said, why don't you imagine like this room is artificially quiet because they turned off the refrigerator, right?
因为它可以或者声音。为什么你不想象冰箱开着，你必须谈论它？哦，演员会那样做。你知道，它把这个像，而且不仅仅是一件小事。就像，哦，演员必须。把所有这些，所有那些小细节。它必须证明任何需要做的事情是合理的。他们不仅仅做感觉真实的事情。
Because it could or sound. Why don't you imagine that the refrigerator's on and you have to talk about it? Oh, an actor does that. You know, it put this like, and it wasn't just like one little thing. It was like, oh, an actor has to. to put all these, all those little details. It has to justify anything that needs to be done. They don't just do what feels real.
他们必须像找到一种方法来做他们需要做的事情，并让它感觉真实。我喜欢听这个。这是你带到其他项目的东西吗？保罗，作为编剧、剧集主管、节目创作者，你有没有要求你的编剧团队去表演？我有。让我们看看，我被放鸽子了。我有布里茨（Blitz）的兄弟，安迪·布里茨（Andy Blitz）。
They have to like find a way to do what they need to do and make it feel real. I love hearing that. Is this something that you've brought to other projects? Paul, as a writer, showrunner, creator of shows, have you asked your writing staff to act at all? I did. Let's see, I'm ghosted. I had Blitz's brother, Andy Blitz.
我为他创造了一个角色。嗯，我必须说，珍娜和我谈过很多次，当格雷格加入时我们也谈过，我们喜欢我们能和编剧们在一起。我们喜欢当我们能去编剧室的时候。有时我们会在仓库那边拍摄，那里有通往你们放零食的厨房的后楼梯，我们会上去闲逛。你们在片场对我们来说真的很有趣。现在很难想象没有那种创意合作和那种安全感与信任感的其他节目。
And I'm created a part for him. Well, I have to say, and Jenna and I have talked about this a lot, and we talked about this when Greg came on as well, that we loved that we got to be around the writers. We loved when we got to go up into the writer's room. Sometimes we would shoot over in the warehouse, and there was that back stairwell that went up where your kitchen was with your snacks, and we would come up and hang out. And it was really fun for us to have you guys on set. And it's hard for me to imagine other shows now without that creative collaboration and that feeling of safety and trust.
我们都曾在其他节目工作过，情况并非如此。这是我真正珍惜的东西。是的，我也是。我是对的。它，打破那堵墙让我们更好地理解了彼此。我们都一起工作。嗯，说到为这一集组队。工作，你和迈克·舒尔组队了。
And we've all worked on other shows where it is not the case. And it's something that I really cherish. Yeah, me too. I was right. It was, it would, breaking down that wall made, made us understand each other a lot better. And we all work together. Well, speaking of having to team up for this episode. the job, you teamed up with Mike Schur.
你们共同编写了这一集。那是怎么运作的？我有一种记忆，你知道，这是在季末，漫长的赛季。很多剧集是以不同的方式编写的。所以并不是迈克和我一起走进一个房间，然后带着节目出来。我想我们都在一起运行编写这一集的过程。你知道，我们会和一些编剧进进出出地敲定它，但我们是那里确保，你知道，这一集是我们想要的那个样子的两个人。
You guys co-wrote this episode. How did that work? I have kind of a memory of, you know, this was at the end of the season and long season. And a lot of episodes are written in different ways. So it wasn't that Mike and I went off into a room together and then came out with the show. I think that we both were running the process of writing this episode together. You know, and we would, we beat it all out with some writers would come in and out, but we would be the two people that was there making sure, you know, the episode was what we wanted.
然后他会去拍一个场景。我会拍一个场景，或者他会带几个编剧去拍一个场景，我也会做同样的事情。我想这基本上就是这一集的工作方式。很有趣你提到在这样的团队中工作，因为我记得在片场有几次格雷格会把我叫出片场。他会说，珍娜，你在场景里吗？你在场景里吗？好吧，我有三个编剧在谈论吉姆和帕姆。我想让你旁听。进去。进去。哦，天哪，我会变得非常兴奋。我会像，哦，我等不及了。我等不及了。我大部分时间只是听。有时我会提出想法，但这太酷了。因为你们会把一个
And then he would go take a scene. I would take a scene or he would take a few writers to take a scene and I would do the same. I think that's basically how this one worked. It's funny that you mentioned working in groups like that because I remember there were times on the set where Greg would call me offset. He would say, Jenna, are you in the scene? Are you in the scene? Okay, I've got three writers talking about Jim and Pam. I want you to sit in on that. Go in there. Go in there. Oh, my gosh, I would get so excited. I would be like, oh, I can't wait. I can't wait. And I mostly just listened. And sometimes I would throw out ideas, but that was so cool. Because you guys would kind of divide up a
剧本分开，像一组三个人去处理德怀特的事情。然后另外三个人去处理故事的其他方面，至少从我在编剧室的一点经验来看是这样。嗯，这是一集一集来的，你知道，有些是真正由编剧构思并一直贯穿到底的，有些是非常协作的。但即使当一个编剧独自完成时，你知道，关于将要发生什么也有大量的讨论。嗯，这一集的一个大故事线是简和迈克尔复合了，简做了隆胸手术。我们对这个故事线很好奇。
script and like a group of three people would go work on Dwight stuff. And then another three people would work on some other aspect of the story, at least from my little bit of experience in the writer's room. Well, it was episode by episode, you know, and some came in, some were really, like, conceived by the writer and went straight all the way through, and some were extremely collaborative. But even when a writer did it by himself, herself, there was, you know, there was tons of discussion about what was going to happen. Well, a big storyline, in this episode is that Jan and Michael get back together and Jan has had breast augmentation. And we're so curious about this storyline.
比如，它是怎么来的？你和马洛拉（Melora）谈过吗，和马洛拉以及史蒂夫一起工作？那是什么感觉？我想墙上有一张卡片很久了。我说，简做了隆胸。我们当时在寻找合适的地方。然后我们不得不分手。她做了隆胸，因为那个他们复合了，这是发生的事情
Like, how did it come about? Did you talk to Malora about it and working with Malora and Steve? What was that like? I think there was a card on the wall for a long time. I said, Jan gets a boobjo. And we were kind of looking for the right place. And then so we had to break up. she gets a boot job and it's because of that they get back together it was something that happened
在《鸡尾酒会》期间，简在大卫·华莱士家门前的草坪上做了一个超长的访谈，是的，在大卫·华莱士家门前。在编写那个时，我们有点发现了简是如何走上自我毁灭之路的。是的，它就像那样为我们结晶了。就像，哦，她正在带自己去拥有。一旦我们得到了那个，这就是她螺旋式上升的一个阶段。嗯，这太精彩了。我只是觉得马洛拉和史蒂夫再次，他们作为简和迈克尔的动态对我来说，太棒了。太棒了。我可以整天看着他们。我这一集最喜欢的部分是她第一次回来的时候。他只是看着她。珍妮，你就在那里，你往下看。
during cocktails jane did this super long talking head on the lawn of the um yes in front of david wallace's house yeah in front of david wallace's house and in writing that um we kind of discovered how jan was on the road to self-destruction yes it was like that crystallized it for us it's like oh she's taking herself to have. Once we got that, this was like a stage in her spiral. Well, it's so brilliant. I just thought Malora and Steve just once again, their dynamic as Jan and Michael to me, it's just so good. So good. I could watch them all day. My favorite part of the episode was when she came back in for the first time. And he's just looking at her. And Jenny, you're right there and you're looking down.
是的，他就像，为什么私下？为什么私下？我喜欢我被直接放在他们两个中间。是的。那本来可能只是一个平淡无奇的小场景。你知道，但他走在这条线上
Yeah, he's like, why privately? Why privately? I loved how I was put right in the middle of the two of them. Yeah. It could have been just such a normal little dud of a scene. You know, but he walked this line of
既刻薄又试图礼貌和震惊，并且吓坏了。吓坏了，吓坏了，并同时让这一切变得真实。是的。看到他那样做太搞笑了。
of being like mean and trying to be polite and shocked and freaking that. freaking freaking out and making it all real at once. Yeah. It was so funny to see him do that.
我必须问你谁负责《克里德思想》（Creed Thoughts）。我想那是迈克的一个访谈。然后杰森·凯斯勒（Jason Kessler）在博客上做了。我想他在NBC.com上做了一个《克里德思想》的博客。他是你们的编剧助理？是这样吗？是的。是的。
I have to ask you who is responsible for creed thoughts. I think that was a mic talking head. And then Jason Kessler did it on the blog. He did a blog of creed thoughts on NBC.com, I guess. And he was your writer's assistant? Is that right? Yeah. Yeah.
然后他有点接管了，嗯，数字媒体方面的事情。我这周给克里德发了短信。我说，克里德，你还记得《克里德思想》吗？你的整个博客？他说，是的，是的，那很有趣。我没写那些。但那个博客持续了一年，杰森以克里德的名义写的。
And then he kind of took over the, um, digital media stuff. I texted Creed about it this week. I was like, Creed, do you remember Creed thoughts? Your whole blog? He was like, yeah, yeah, that was fun. I didn't write any of that. But that went on for a year, that blog that Jason wrote as creed.
是的。好吧，所以这一集介绍了“精明币”（Schrute Bucks），这太搞笑了。是谁想出来的？而且，我存了一个。我有一个精明币。你有？是的。是装裱起来的吗？
Yeah. Okay, so this episode introduces the shrewd bucks, which are hilarious. And who came up with that? And also, I saved one. I have a shrewd buck. You do? Yeah. Is it frame?
不，我想我应该把它装裱起来。它可能，它就像在一个我还没整理的剪贴簿箱子里。嗯，那会做到的。它是大的还是小的，安吉拉？它是大的。好的。而且我不知道你们记不记得，我想这是一个删除的场景，但克里德试图淹没，淹没美元的价值，试图淹没市场。所以他有这个删除的场景，他在疯狂地复印，他四处张望，确保没人看到他。
No, I guess I should frame it. It's probably, it's like in a scrapbook bin that I haven't gotten to. Well, that'll do it. Is it a large one or a small one, Angela? It's the large one. Okay. And I don't know if you guys remember, I think it's a deleted scene, but Creed tries to flood, flood the value of the dollar, try to flood the market. So he has this deleted scene where he's photocopying like crazy and he's looking around, make sure no one's seeing him.
然后他推着这整车成千上万的精明币到德怀特那里，就像德怀特的新办公室。他说，我要用这些宝贝淹没市场，除非你付钱。所以我的记忆是它们在片场到处都是。我们有一堆。我忘了那个场景了。是的。它没有进入正片，但它真的很有趣。是的，那很有趣。
And then he wheels in to Dwight, like Dwight's new office, this whole cart full of thousands of shrewbucks. And he's like, I'm going to flood the market with these babies unless you pay up. So my memory is they were everywhere on set. We had stacks of them. I forgot about that scene. Yeah. It's not, it didn't make it, but it's really funny. Yeah, that is funny.
我想。是贾斯汀·斯皮策（Justin Spitzer）想到了精明币。哦，他太搞笑了。不是100%。是的，他很棒。而且他喜欢德怀特。多年来有很多德怀特的东西都是出自他之手。嗯，贾斯汀做了双胞胎吸收。
I think that. that Justin Spitzer thought of Shrewd box. Oh, he's so funny. Not 100%. Yeah, he's great. And he loved Dwight. There was a lot of Dwight stuff over the years that came out of him. Well, Justin did twin absorption.
我们发现了。是的，是的。是的。这对我来说引出了一个有趣的事情，保罗，就是我记得多年来会有不同的编剧真的非常喜欢某个特定的角色。比如，迈克·舒尔喜欢看安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin）崩溃。我总能看出什么时候是他的剧本，我的角色会陷入困境。你有没有特别喜欢为其写作的角色？我想我喜欢写每个人。
We found out. Yes, yes. Yeah. That brings up an interesting thing to me, Paul, is that I remember over the years there'd be different writers that would just really love a specific character. Like, Mike Scher loved to see Angela. Lamarton fall apart. I could always tell when it was one of his scripts, my character would spiral out. Did you have a character that you love to write for? I love doing everybody, I think.
克里德总是很有趣。凯文总是，就像，很有趣，只是推向极限。所以最终做了一个他不知道字母表的。我记得和他走得那么远。我当时，我在做的时候笑得太厉害了。迈克尔。我有时仍然，就像，我在开车，我想起迈克尔的一个访谈。我不想写。你知道，他的声音在我脑海里太清晰了。
The creed was always fun. Kevin was always, like, fun to just push to the limits. So eventually doing one where he didn't know the alphabet. I remember going that far with him. I was just, I was laughing so hard during one. while he was doing it. Michael. I still sometimes, like, I'm driving and I think of like a Michael talking head. I don't want to write. You know, his voice is just so clear in my head.
太独特了。是的。你知道，我怀念一个角色。我当时在为他写作。嗯，保罗，你有没有像这一集里最喜欢的场景或时刻，或者任何你想分享的东西，比如最喜欢的时刻？甚至不需要是这一集里的，但如果有的话。我真的笑了。
It was so distinct. Yeah. You know, I miss a character. I was writing for him. Well, Paul, do you have like a favorite scene or moment from this episode or anything you want to share, like a favorite moment? It doesn't even have to be from this episode, but if there was one. I really laughed.
很大声，当亨特（Hunter）的时候，他告诉亨特，告诉她，我想挤压它们。是的。她会知道我的意思。这很好。就像，告诉她，布伦（Brun）。是的。现在，我在剧本里看了，第二部分不在剧本里。我有一种感觉。
that loud when Hunter, and he was telling Hunter, tell her, I want to squeeze them. Yeah. She'll know what I mean. It's good. Like, tell her, brun. Yeah. Now, I looked in the script and the second part was not in the script. I had a feeling.
哦，太好了。我很高兴你查了它，因为我当时，我当时在想。我敢打赌他是即兴发挥的。但第一个是告诉她，我想挤压它们。她会知道这意味着什么，是在里面的。是的。然后我喜欢，当简发现她被解雇了，她冲进华莱士的房间。
Oh, good. I'm glad you checked it out because I was, I was wondering. I bet he improvised that. But the first one was the teller, I want to squeeze them. She'll know what it means was in there. Yes. And then I loved, when Jan finds out, she's fired and she storms into Wallace's room.
他们有这种尖叫比赛，他斥责了她。我喜欢大卫表现得多么坚强。就像他只是那么冷静，我觉得，是的，那是一个非常扎实的角色，因为在那部剧里很多人只是有点害怕或抑制说出真相。好的。所以然后有这个时刻，在她离开后，迈克尔站在门框后面说，我没告诉她。
They have this kind of screaming match and he tells her off. And I loved how strong David was. Like he was just so collected and I felt like, yeah, that was just really solid character to have, because so many people are just kind of scared or inhibited to say the truth on that show. Okay. So then there's this moment after she leaves where Michael's standing behind the dorm frame and says, I didn't tell her.
这真的不是什么像不是我。他甚至不能看。而且他，库普（Quapis）构图的方式是他有点像门框正好落在他的脸中间。我喜欢，我喜欢当，你知道，简只是让大卫·华莱士拥有它。而迈克尔就在你说的那个位置。有一瞬间，他就像，是的。然后大卫·华莱士就像，对不起？就像，只是用一个眼神。
It wasn't really something like it wasn't me. And he can't even look. And he's, the way Coop has framed it was he was kind of like the door frame was right coming down in the middle of his face. I loved, I loved when, you know, Jan is just like letting David Wallace have it. And Michael is in that same spot you're talking about. And for one moment, he's like, yeah. And then David Wallace is like, excuse me? Like, just with a look.
是的。迈克尔就像，不，不，好的，好的。我只是，我只是，但没有。不。不。不。不。嗯，我们有一个粉丝的问题，保罗，我必须问。
Yeah. And Michael's like, nope, nope, okay, okay. I just, I just, but no. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Well, we got one question from a fan, Paul, and I have to ask.
这是来自莎拉·麦金蒂（Sarah McGinty）和朱怡王（Zhu Yi Wang）。他们想知道为什么凯伦没有得到总公司的工作？因为你设定了工作的要求之一是四年的销售经验。但瑞恩（Ryan），我们不认为他在那里工作了四年，而且他从来没有做过销售。为什么大卫·华莱士选择了他是因为你想让BJ离开片场进入编剧室
This is from Sarah McGinty and Zhu Yi Wang. They want to know why didn't Karen get the job at corporate? Because you set up that one of the requirements for the job was sales experience of four years. But Ryan, we don't think has worked there for four years and he's never made a sale. why did David Wallace choose him? They want to know, did you do this so that you could get BJ off the set and into the writer's room
这样他就能做他的编剧工作了吗？不，可能恰恰相反。我想我们觉得我们会通过让瑞恩当迈克尔的老板一段时间来获得很多有趣的喜剧效果。你知道，他是进来的临时工。他显然是一个非常好的胡说八道者，但，但不称职，你知道。我想这就是他得到它的方式，你知道。
so he could do his writing job? No, probably the opposite. I think we felt we would get a lot of fun comedy out of putting Ryan as Michael's boss for a while. You know, he was the temp that came in. He's clearly a really good bullshit shitter, but it's, but incompetent, you know. And I think that's how he got it, you know.
我想我们说他去管理学校待了一会儿。他拿到了MBA，对吧？那是其中之一。我不确定他是怎么做到的，也许是在晚上。但是，我的意思是，现实世界中的推理，你知道，可能是，他只是用MBA真正让大卫眼花缭乱，并说了所有正确的话。所以我能看到，我能看到它发生。但真正的原因是，你知道，是时候了
I think we say he went to management school for a little. He got an MBA, right? That was one of the things. I'm not sure how he did that, maybe at night. But, I mean, the reasoning in the real world, you know, I could have been, he just really kind of dazzled David with the NBA and said all the right things. So I could see, I can see it happening. But the real reason was like, you know, it was time.
让凯伦离开这部剧，你知道我们对吉姆和帕姆在第四季做了什么，然后我们认为这将是一个有趣的动态转换
for caring to leave the show and you know what we were doing with Jim and Pam for season four and then we thought it would be just a fun dynamic switch
我想这是一个当我们总是寻找这些配对时，你知道，转换人们，谁有一段时间没在一起了，你知道，所以我们有你们所有的照片，但你和你呢，我们做过一个场景，如果你是他的老板会怎么样，你知道，你总是像
I think it's a When we were always looking for these pairings you know switch people up who hasn't been together in a while you know so we have all your pictures up but what about you and you have we done a scene with what if you were his boss you know and you're always like
我觉得这是一种当我们一直在寻找这些搭档组合时，你知道，把那些很久没在一起的人换一下，你知道，所以我们把你们的照片都挂出来，但你呢，我们有没有和你拍过一场戏，如果他是你的上司会怎样，你知道，你总是像
sat you know status games and improv or power dynamics, you know, just switching them up. I loved it. I just loved it so much. I could really see why Ryan at corporate would just be, it's almost Shakespearean, you know, it's like Michael thinks of himself as the king and this like lowly, like peasant just went right past him, you know, on the food chain. And I love that he was like, give me a coffee, you know.
你知道地位游戏和即兴表演，或者权力动态，你知道，就是转换它们。我喜欢它。我真的太喜欢了。我真的能看出为什么公司里的瑞安会那样，这几乎是莎士比亚式的，你知道，就像迈克尔认为自己是国王，而这个卑微的，像农民一样的人直接越过了他，你知道，在食物链上。我喜欢他说，给我一杯咖啡，你知道。
And then now, now Ryan just jumped right. over him and it's going to be at corporate. And just the way he says goodbye to Kelly, he's like cold. He's cold-hearted. But you can see that there's going to be some fun there. Yeah. Yeah. He's like, we're done.
然后现在，瑞安直接跳过了他，要去公司总部了。他跟帕姆告别的方式，他就像冷酷无情。他是冷酷无情的。但你可以看出那里会有一些乐趣。是的。是的。他说，我们完了。
Yeah. Paul, is there anything when you look back and you think to yourself, I wish we had done this scene? Because I remember there was a card on the writer's room wall for years and years and years that never got made and it haunts me and it said double date and it was going to be a double date with jim and pam and dwight and angela and i always wish we had seen that double date and i even remember being in the writer's room and hearing you guys try to justify why jim and pam would agree to go on a double date with twice and angela how could our vice versa how why why would
是的。保罗，当你回首往事，心想，我真希望我们拍了那个场景吗？因为我记得编剧室的墙上贴着一张卡片，贴了好多年好多年，从来没拍过，它一直困扰着我，上面写着“双重约会”，本来是吉姆和帕姆，还有德怀特和安吉拉的双重约会，我一直希望我们能看到那个双重约会，我甚至记得在编剧室里听到你们试图证明为什么吉姆和帕姆会同意和德怀特与安吉拉进行双重约会，或者反过来，为什么，为什么
Angela ever attend. And I think dinner party was sort of that, right? We all did go out on our kind of double triple date there, quadruple date, really, since Dwight brought his babysitter. Were there any cards that you remember that you had to leave
安吉拉会参加。我想《晚宴》就是那种情况，对吧？我们都去参加了我们的那种双重三重约会，实际上是四重约会，因为德怀特带了他的保姆。你还记得有什么卡片是你不得不留在墙上的吗？你不得不把它们留在后面？
on the wall? You had to leave them behind? I'm absolutely sure there were. Double date would have been fun. Sometimes it's finding the killer joke. Like we maybe, you know, we should have been just been pitching on what is the hysterical thing that's going to happen because then we find that and you're like, we'll do whatever it takes to just. Paul, thank you so much for coming on office ladies. We were just thrilled to have you. Thanks for having me on. Yeah. Well, thanks, Paul. It was
我绝对肯定有。双重约会本来会很有趣。有时是找到那个杀手锏笑话。就像我们可能，你知道，我们本应该一直在推销什么是会发生的歇斯底里的事情，因为一旦我们找到了那个，你就会说，我们会不惜一切代价去完成它。保罗，非常感谢你来到《办公室女士》。我们很高兴你能来。谢谢邀请我。是的。好吧，谢谢，保罗。很高兴见到你。
really good to see you. And I hope that we can have another get together really soon. I hope so all right. All right, Paul. Take care, guys. Bye, Paul. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Well, that was just too much fun. I love it when we have writers on the show. And Paul is the writer-actor. He brings such a cool perspective, right, Jenna? Yeah.
我希望我们能很快再聚一次。我希望如此。好的。好的，保罗。保重，伙计们。再见，保罗。再见。再见。再见。再见。好吧，那真是太有趣了。我喜欢我们有编剧来节目。保罗既是编剧又是演员。他带来了如此酷的视角，对吧，珍娜？是的。
Well, listen, we want to give Paul a shout out here. He has a really funny new project coming out, spring of 2021. It's going to be on Audible, and it's a show called Captain. He said it's like an old-time radio show, and it's a sci-fi, but it's anti- sci-fi. I love this description. It's anti- sci-fi. Jenna's like, I'm on board. It has Will Forte, John Malkovich, Rain Wilson, Adam Scott, Wyatt Sannack, Gillian Jacobs, lots of funny folks. Be looking for it, Spring 2021. Captain on Audible. Yeah. He said it's like they're all out in space, but there's nothing sci-fi happening to them. Which I just thought was so funny. I can't wait. I can't wait. Well, listen, guys, we will take a break.
好吧，听着，我们要给保罗一个大大的赞。他有一个非常有趣的新项目要出来，2021年春天。它将在Audible上播出，是一个叫《船长》的节目。他说这就像一个老式的广播节目，它是科幻，但它是反科幻的。我喜欢这个描述。它是反科幻的。珍娜说，我加入了。它有威尔·福特、约翰·马尔科维奇、雷恩·威尔逊、亚当·斯科特、怀亚特·塞纳克、吉莉安·雅各布斯，很多有趣的人。敬请期待，2021年春天。Audible上的《船长》。是的。他说就像他们都在太空中，但没有发生任何科幻的事情。我觉得这太有趣了。我等不及了。我等不及了。好吧，听着，伙计们，我们要休息一下。
And then when we come back, we will start breaking down the job. Woo. All right. So this episode opens with Michael at corporate for his interview, which is tomorrow. Yeah, he got the day wrong. And now he's got to cover his butt. Yeah, he's trying to save it, and he does a horrible job. Yeah.
然后当我们回来时，我们将开始分析这份工作。呜。好的。所以这一集以迈克尔在公司总部面试开始，面试是明天。是的，他记错日子了。现在他得掩盖自己的屁股。是的，他试图挽救它，但他做得太糟糕了。是的。
And I wanted to point out something while him and David Wallace are talking, I looked at reception, no plants at reception corporate. Oh, my gosh, now you're tracking the plants at corporate reception. What's wrong with me? But at 33 seconds, there is a really good shot of some dried brown sticks in the back. It's like sticks, big, tall looking sticks. I mean, they're not really alive, right? This is some kind of decor. Well, clearly, the receptionist at corporate is doing something right.
我想指出一件事，当他和大卫·华莱士交谈时，我看了看接待处，公司总部的接待处没有植物。哦，天哪，现在你在追踪公司接待处的植物了。我怎么了？但在33秒时，后面有一张非常好的干枯棕色树枝的照片。就像树枝，又大又高的树枝。我的意思是，它们不是真的活的，对吧？这是一种装饰。好吧，显然，公司总部的接待员做对了什么。
She doesn't have to keep any plants alive. She's just got a jar with sticks. I like it. Pam could learn something. We should get into the episode. So Jim arrives to work and Jenna, Jim has a new haircut. He does. Meredith thinks it looks sexy.
她不必让任何植物活着。她只有一个装满树枝的罐子。我喜欢它。帕姆可以学到一些东西。我们应该进入这一集。所以吉姆到达工作岗位，珍娜，吉姆换了新发型。他换了。梅雷迪斯觉得它看起来很性感。
Oh, yeah. and Kevin thinks he could look worse. Andy immediately says, you're no longer Big Tuna, your big haircut. Well, we got a lot of fan questions about this, Angela. Samantha Patino, Kayla O, Katie Nolder, Jess Con, Natalie Payne, and many others wrote in to ask, was Jim's haircut a writer choice,
哦，是的。凯文觉得他看起来可能更糟。安迪立刻说，你不再是“大金枪鱼”了，你是“大发型”。好吧，我们收到了很多关于这个的粉丝问题，安吉拉。萨曼莎·帕蒂诺、凯拉·O、凯蒂·诺尔德、杰斯·康、娜塔莉·佩恩和许多其他人写信问，吉姆的发型是编剧的选择，
or was there another reason he got the haircut? It was both. It was both. It was in the script, but it had to be in the script, because John got a haircut. Well, John was doing a movie with George Clooney and Renee Zillwicker called Leatherheads. And it was set in a different time
还是他换发型有其他原因？两者都有。两者都有。它在剧本里，但它必须在剧本里，因为约翰剪了头发。好吧，约翰正在和乔治·克鲁尼和蕾妮·齐薇格拍一部叫《爱情达阵》的电影。它设定在不同的时代，
and so he had shorter hair. But it worked out perfect for the story because I think it's great that Karen's like, you need a haircut. You're going to interview for corporate. And Jim did kind of have this shaggy hair, you know? So I like that Karen as the girlfriend was like, you've got to clean it up.
所以他的头发更短了。但这对于故事来说非常完美，因为我觉得凯伦说“你需要剪头发。你要去公司总部面试”这很棒。吉姆确实有这种蓬乱的头发，你知道吗？所以我喜欢凯伦作为女朋友说，你得把它整理一下。
But there were a few episodes this season. Some of you guys have asked that, that as John's hair was sort of transitioning back from that haircut of the movie that he did wear a wig. Yes, and we have not talked about that, which is so crazy to me. But yeah, after he got the super short haircut
但这一季有几集。你们中的一些人问过，当约翰的头发从他拍电影剪的那个发型过渡回来时，他确实戴了假发。是的，我们还没有谈过这个，这对我来说太疯狂了。但是是的，在他剪了超短发之后
for the movie, he came back to the office and he had to wear a wig for a while where his hair grew out. And then finally, for this episode, I think they felt like it had grown out enough that it looked like a more modern day haircut. So this is John's real hair, folks. Yes, yes.
为了那部电影，他回到办公室，有一段时间他不得不戴假发，直到他的头发长出来。然后最后，对于这一集，我想他们觉得它已经长得足够长了，看起来像一个更现代的发型。所以这是约翰的真头发，伙计们。是的，是的。
You guys, I went to the Leatherheads premiere and I met John's family and I could not believe it. I walked up to the group of them and John was like, hey, guys, this is my friend Angela. And they turned around and they were the tallest people. John is the shortest of his brothers, guys. And he's like six, three. He's six, three. He's the shortest. I was like, oh my gosh.
伙计们，我去了《爱情达阵》的首映式，我见到了约翰的家人，我简直不敢相信。我走到他们那群人面前，约翰说，嘿，伙计们，这是我的朋友安吉拉。他们转过身来，他们是最高的人。约翰是他兄弟中最矮的，伙计们。他有6英尺3英寸。他有6英尺3英寸。他是最矮的。我说，哦，天哪。
It was like we're from two different planets. But they were so lovely and that was so fun to be able to go support him like that. Yeah. Yeah, that was really cool when he was shooting that movie, actually. We would get excited for each other when we would get these jobs. And we'd be like, tell us all about it. I know. I was like George Clooney. Come on. I know. I wanted to point out something, though, with his talking head, you know, he says that Karen suggested he'd get a haircut for his interview. And Jenna, this is a major girlfriend moment. I mean, A, it shows that Jim is actually really listening to Karen. You know, you're changing your look, especially when you've had the same haircut or same look for years and years, that's a big deal. And so he took her advice and I thought, oh, wow, their relationship's really solid. Like, I was believing it. I'm like, wow, Jim's all in. And then I thought it also shows that he really wants to get the job.
就像我们来自两个不同的星球。但他们非常可爱，能够去那样支持他真是太有趣了。是的。是的，当他拍那部电影时，这真的很酷。当我们得到这些工作时，我们会为彼此感到兴奋。我们会说，告诉我们关于它的一切。我知道。我说乔治·克鲁尼。得了吧。我知道。不过，我想指出他谈话时的一件事，你知道，他说凯伦建议他为面试剪个头发。珍娜，这是一个重大的女朋友时刻。我的意思是，A，它表明吉姆实际上真的在听凯伦的话。你知道，你改变你的外表，特别是当你多年来一直留着同样的发型或同样的外表时，那是一件大事。所以他听取了她的建议，我想，哦，哇，他们的关系真的很稳固。就像，我相信它。我说，哇，吉姆全心全意。然后我想这也表明他真的很想得到这份工作。
Well, in this episode, there are going to be a ton of Mr. X. we do not show our hand for what the end of this is going to be at all. And coming back from beach games, it was like, what is going to be the repercussion of Pam's confession on the beach? And so to open this episode with Jim and Karen stronger than ever, Pam is like, listen, it went great. It was fine. She has that whole talking head where she's like, I know,
好吧，在这一集中，会有大量的X先生。我们根本没有展示这一集的结局会是什么。从海滩游戏回来，就像，帕姆在海滩上的坦白会有什么后果？所以以吉姆和凯伦比以往任何时候都更强大来开启这一集，帕姆就像，听着，进展顺利。没关系。她有整个谈话环节，她说，我知道，
it only took me three years to summon the courage to tell Jim my feelings. But, you know, I'm glad I did it and now it's over. We're all moving on. That's how we open this episode. We're all moving on. Jim has a haircut. He likes his girlfriend's advice. I was really, I don't even know the word, like in awe maybe of Pam's talking head about how she was like, I have no regrets.
我花了三年时间才鼓起勇气告诉吉姆我的感受。但是，你知道，我很高兴我这么做了，现在它结束了。我们都在继续前进。这就是我们开启这一集的方式。我们都在继续前进。吉姆剪了头发。他喜欢他女朋友的建议。我真的，我甚至不知道那个词，就像对帕姆的谈话环节感到敬畏，关于她怎么说，我没有遗憾。
It needed to be said and I said it because I would have been horrified. I would have been so embarrassed like that I have this huge like emotional speech in front of all of my coworkers. But then you got to show up to work the next day with everyone in the bright fluorescent light. Yeah. Well, they do teaser a little bit. They're a bunch in deleted scenes. There's a runner. And we'll see one later.
它需要被说出来，我说了，因为我会感到恐惧。我会感到非常尴尬，就像我在所有同事面前发表了这么大的情感演讲。但然后你第二天还得去上班，在每个人明亮的荧光灯下。是的。好吧，他们确实预告了一点。有很多删除的场景。有一个跑动。我们稍后会看到一个。
But you do get made fun of a little bit, but lovingly by everyone. Yes. Well, next up, Michael is in his office. He calls Dwight in. And he explains, it's time for me to name my successor. he hands Dwight an envelope. Yes. And inside there is a written note from Michael that says, Dwight, congratulations, A-Wipe. Don't screw the pooch. This brings Dwight begins sobbing. It brings Dwight. Sobbing. Sobbing tears. I listened to the DVD commentary and they said in the commentary that Rain is Dwight went on and on so long sobbing. They just let him just sob. Ken Quaphas just let him just let him. go and let them go. And Ken said it went on for so long. And Steve started saying, you know what,
但你确实被嘲笑了一点，但每个人都充满爱意。是的。好吧，接下来，迈克尔在他的办公室里。他叫德怀特进来。他解释说，是时候让我任命我的继任者了。他递给德怀特一个信封。是的。里面有一张迈克尔写的便条，上面写着，德怀特，恭喜，A-Wipe。别搞砸了。这让德怀特开始啜泣。这让德怀特啜泣。啜泣流泪。我听了DVD评论，他们在评论中说，雷恩作为德怀特啜泣的时间太长了。他们只是让他啜泣。肯·夸皮斯只是让他，只是让他。走，让他们走。肯说它持续了太久。史蒂夫开始说，你知道吗，
just forget it. Give me the letter back. I take it back. Well, we had a fan catch in the scene, which is really delightful, Angela. Christina Juarez and John Sperry wrote in to say in Michael's office, when he Hans Dwight, the letter, you can see an outlet on the wall behind Michael. And it is upside down. what is going on here? And oh my God, Angela, it is. It is right around three minutes, 11 seconds by the coat rack behind Michael. It's an upside down electrical outlet. Like the little whole part is on the top and then the two lines are underneath it.
算了。把信还给我。我收回它。好吧，我们在这一幕中有一个粉丝捕捉，这真的很有趣，安吉拉。克里斯蒂娜·华雷斯和约翰·斯佩里写信说，在迈克尔的办公室里，当他把信递给德怀特时，你可以看到迈克尔身后墙上的一个插座。它是倒过来的。这里发生了什么？哦，天哪，安吉拉，确实是。就在3分11秒，迈克尔身后的衣架旁边。这是一个倒过来的电源插座。就像那个小洞部分在上面，然后两条线在它下面。
I know what an upside down outlet would look like. But thank you for, thank you for like walking us through it. Well, if you want to see one go to three minutes and 11 seconds. Well, that's a great catch. You guys know, I will go back and look for it. Here's something, Angela. Of course, we know that that outlet didn't really work. It was just, you know, a fake outlet cover, but it did get me wondering.
我知道倒过来的插座是什么样子的。但谢谢你，谢谢你带我们了解它。好吧，如果你想看一个，去3分11秒。好吧，那是一个很棒的捕捉。你们知道，我会回去找它的。这里有一件事，安吉拉。当然，我们知道那个插座并没有真正工作。它只是，你知道，一个假的插座盖，但它确实让我感到好奇。
So I went to the website, family handyman.com. Oh, Lord. And it says that there is actually no right way to install an outlet. You can install it, quote, upside down. you can install it sideways, it will not affect how the outlet works. It actually said, quote, it's up to you. There's no standard electrical outlet orientation, so there's really no such thing as an upside down outlet. Well, that makes sense.
所以我去了网站，family handyman.com。哦，天哪。它说实际上没有安装插座的正确方法。你可以安装它，引用“倒过来”。你可以侧着安装它，它不会影响插座的工作方式。它实际上说，引用“这取决于你”。没有标准的电源插座方向，所以真的没有所谓的倒过来的插座。好吧，这说得通。
It does make sense. I found it interesting. I feel like I definitely need to tell my dad about family handyman.com. Oh, your dad will love it. I also want to say, before we move on, that I noticed that there are also too light switches in the middle of Michael's wall underneath a giant framed picture. Now, that is odd. Why would you put your light switches there? I guess it's because when you walk in the door, he has like glass, so you can't. But he has to walk real far into his office to turn on the
这确实说得通。我觉得它很有趣。我觉得我绝对需要告诉我爸爸关于family handyman.com的事。哦，你爸爸会喜欢的。我还想说，在我们继续之前，我注意到迈克尔墙中间，在一张巨大的装裱照片下面，也有两个电灯开关。现在，这很奇怪。你为什么要在那儿放电灯开关？我想是因为当你走进门时，他有玻璃，所以你不能。但他必须走到他办公室很深的地方才能打开
lights. I'm just saying. Well, you know what? He never has to do it because Dwight gets there early and sets up his office for him. Yeah. Michael doesn't even know where those lights switches are He's never had to turn him on. Well, they're right there under the picture. You know what, Angela, you spot plants. I'm going to be on the lookout for outlets. Well, between the two of us, look out, world. That's right.
灯。我只是说。好吧，你知道吗？他从来不需要这样做，因为德怀特很早就到了，为他布置办公室。是的。迈克尔甚至不知道那些灯开关在哪里。他从来不需要打开它们。好吧，它们就在照片下面。你知道吗，安吉拉，你发现植物。我会留意插座的。好吧，我们两个，小心了，世界。没错。
Well, next up, the scene between Pam and Karen. Oh, my gosh. I thought Rashida did such an amazing job because she had to react to so many things as Karen. First of all, she's graciously, I think, trying to let Pam off the hook. She's like, you know what? It happens. Sometimes we just have those moments.
好吧，接下来，帕姆和凯伦之间的场景。哦，天哪。我觉得拉希达做得太棒了，因为作为凯伦，她不得不对很多事情做出反应。首先，我觉得她很优雅地试图让帕姆摆脱困境。她说，你知道吗？这发生了。有时我们只是有那些时刻。
We say things we don't mean. And then Pam is like, oh, no, I meant it. I've thought about it a long time. And Karen, the look that comes over her face, she's like, oh, that's how it is. Yeah. And then she has her talking head where she's like, Pam is kind of a bitch. Yeah. Yeah.
我们说了一些我们并不意味着的话。然后帕姆说，哦，不，我是认真的。我想了很久。凯伦，她脸上的表情，她就像，哦，原来是这样。是的。然后她有她的谈话环节，她说，帕姆有点婊子。是的。是的。
I would be ticked off. I would not be happy with Pam. Well, here was my thing as the character of Pam. Because in watching it as an audience member, it was rude. Like, Pam is not being great in that scene. Not being great in that scene. She's also flirting with Jim in front of Karen.
我会很生气的。我不会对帕姆感到高兴。好吧，这是我作为帕姆这个角色的想法。因为作为观众看它，这很粗鲁。就像，帕姆在那个场景中表现得并不好。在那个场景中表现得并不好。她还在凯伦面前和吉姆调情。
It's like all bets are off with Pam now. She walked across these coals. She's feeling empowered. When did she flirt with Jim in front of Karen? Hi. I like your haircut. I like it. Smile.
就像帕姆现在什么都不顾了。她走过了这些煤炭。她感到很有力量。她什么时候在凯伦面前和吉姆调情了？嗨。我喜欢你的发型。我喜欢它。微笑。
Come on. Come on. Right out of the gate. And then later, when he's leaving for corporate, she's like, good luck. Oh my gosh. You have such strong feelings. I didn't know. I feel like Pam is openly flirting with Jim in front of Karen in this episode.
得了吧。得了吧。一出来就是。然后后来，当他要去公司总部时，她说，祝你好运。哦，天哪。你有如此强烈的感情。我不知道。我觉得帕姆在这一集中公开在凯伦面前和吉姆调情。
Okay. My backstory as Pam, it's one of those things where when you finally get, get your voice, you just say everything. You lose all of your editing for a period of time, right? Because you have to try on this new way of being. And you're going to mess it up sometimes. She's, the pendulum has swung in the other direction and Pam is really living in, oh, I'm sorry, I hold nothing back now.
好吧。我作为帕姆的背景故事，这是那种当你终于得到，得到你的声音时，你只是说出一切。你在一段时间内失去了所有的编辑，对吧？因为你必须尝试这种新的存在方式。而且你有时会搞砸它。她，钟摆向另一个方向摆动，帕姆真的生活在，哦，对不起，我现在什么都不保留了。
I give zero Fs. I say it all. And you all are going to have to live with it. That's the world Pam is in right now. Yes, she hasn't auto-corrected to sort of like a happy medium. She's just swung real hard one way. She has. Well, then Karen suggests to Jim that they leave for New York tonight and they should get a hotel room and hang out in the city.
我一点都不在乎。我说了这一切。你们都得忍受它。这就是帕姆现在所处的世界。是的，她没有自动纠正到一种快乐的中间地带。她只是向一个方向摆动得很厉害。她确实。好吧，然后凯伦建议吉姆他们今晚去纽约，他们应该找个酒店房间，在城里逛逛。
Oh, yeah. Karen is like, let's get out of here because that bitch behind reception is coming from my man and we need to go. Well, Angie, we actually had a fan catch from this scene. Anna Owen and Ishaun Vassant both wrote. in to say, at 4 minutes 43 seconds when Karen suggests leaving early, Jim says he has too much paperwork to do and then he signs a document in pencil. Who does that? Did you notice? He signs his name in pencil. It's such a good catch. I did not notice. I did not notice, but I sort of just feel like none of them do any real work all day. Hannah Settle also has a fan catch for this scene.
哦，是的。凯伦就像，让我们离开这里，因为接待处后面的那个婊子在找我的男人，我们需要走。好吧，安吉，我们实际上从这个场景中得到了一个粉丝捕捉。安娜·欧文和伊尚·瓦桑特都写信说，在4分43秒，当凯伦建议早点离开时，吉姆说他有太多的文书工作要做，然后他用铅笔签了一份文件。谁会那样做？你注意到了吗？他用铅笔签了他的名字。这是一个很好的捕捉。我没有注意到。我没有注意到，但我只是觉得他们整天都没有做任何真正的工作。汉娜·塞特尔也为这个场景提供了一个粉丝捕捉。
And it involves you. Oh, what am I doing? At four minutes 33 seconds, Angela and Kevin are talking together in the background. And she wants to know what are some of the things you guys would talk about during scenes when you were in the deep background? Because I watched this scene twice, one, so that I could watch Jim Sign and Pencil. And then two, so that I could watch you and Brian in the background and lady. I know. You and Brian just chatting back.
它涉及你。哦，我在做什么？在4分33秒，安吉拉和凯文在背景中交谈。她想知道当你们在深背景中拍摄场景时，你们会谈论什么？因为我看了这个场景两次，一次，为了看吉姆用铅笔签名。然后两次，为了看你和布莱恩在背景中，女士。我知道。你和布莱恩只是在聊天。
I know, I know. I actually chuckled to myself when I saw this scene because, you know, they had us standing there so we would be in the shot. They would often do that. They would put Brian and I at a file cabinet. And Oscar could stay at his desk because he was in the line of sight. But they would have to pull Brian out and me out. So we would stand at those file cabinets back there. And you guys, we are just shooting the Shataki. We are just like, you know, just like, oh, hey, do you guys want to grab dinner? Yeah, what's up? And Oscar's job was to be our lookout. Okay? He didn't sign up for this job. We just made him do it. So he would under his breath say, guys are kind of swinging over. Camera swinging over. And then sometimes... So that you could like suddenly like snap back into character. And then sometimes he wouldn't catch it. And then all of a sudden, Brian, and I would love it if there was one moment during the run of the show that it was on camera, he would flick me, you know? He'd like flick my arm, like, start talking. That's amazing. We're just, you know, we're just the idiots back there. just chatting it up in accounting.
我知道，我知道。当我看到这个场景时，我实际上对自己笑了，因为，你知道，他们让我们站在那里，这样我们就会在镜头里。他们经常那样做。他们会把布莱恩和我放在文件柜旁。奥斯卡可以留在他的办公桌前，因为他在视线范围内。但他们不得不把布莱恩拉出来，把我拉出来。所以我们会站在后面的那些文件柜旁。伙计们，我们只是在胡说八道。我们只是，你知道，就像，哦，嘿，你们想去吃晚饭吗？是的，怎么了？奥斯卡的任务是做我们的望风者。好吗？他没有报名参加这份工作。我们只是强迫他做。所以他会压低声音说，伙计们，摄像机要转过来了。摄像机转过来了。然后有时……这样你就可以突然像回到角色中一样。然后有时他没有抓住它。然后突然，布莱恩，如果节目播出期间有那么一刻在镜头里，我会喜欢的，他会弹我，你知道吗？他会弹我的手臂，就像，开始说话。太棒了。我们只是，你知道，我们只是后面的白痴。只是在会计部聊天。
Well, speaking of accounting, we have a very strange scene now where Kevin asked Jim who he thinks is hotter between Karen and Pam. I called this the Kev Perv alert. Yeah. Kevin starts listing off all of what he believes to be the various attributes of Karen and Pam. And Jim, Jim is like, eventually he's like, you know what? I think you should take the rest of the day. try to figure this out and get back to me well at five minutes 37 seconds you see jim kind of put his hand
好吧，说到会计，我们现在有一个非常奇怪的场景，凯文问吉姆他觉得凯伦和帕姆谁更性感。我称之为“凯文色狼警报”。是的。凯文开始列出他认为的凯伦和帕姆的各种属性。吉姆，吉姆就像，最后他说，你知道吗？我觉得你应该休息一天。试着弄清楚这一点，然后回来找我。好吧，在5分37秒，你看到吉姆把手放在
up to his chin like he's considering this hmm right hmm kind of thinking about this in the DVD commentary john said that was his Mike sure impression that right in that moment he was being Mike sure yes that's really good he snuck in an impression in the episode I love that so now Pam goes into the break room and you guys there are more of these scenes where she gets teased but this one made it in Oscar teases her and everyone kind of laughs about her big speech she made to gym and Stanley's like it's the most I ever saw you speak I mean I thought is that Kelly and Kelly's like no that was pathetic like that's no I would never do that no offense and then Meredith is like well you know what everyone was drunk no one remembers that and Creed goes oh I do I blogged about it and now we
下巴上，好像他在考虑这个。嗯，对吧。嗯，有点在想这个。在DVD评论中，约翰说那是他的迈克·舒尔印象，就在那一刻，他正在扮演迈克·舒尔。是的，那真的很好。他在这一集中偷偷加入了一个印象。我喜欢这一点。所以现在帕姆走进休息室，伙计们，有更多这样的场景，她被取笑，但这个场景进去了。奥斯卡取笑她，每个人都对她对吉姆发表的大演讲笑了，斯坦利说，这是我见过你说话最多的一次。我的意思是，我想那是凯利吗？凯利说，不，那太可悲了，就像，不，我永远不会那样做，没有冒犯的意思。然后梅雷迪斯说，好吧，你知道吗，每个人都喝醉了，没人记得那个。克里德说，哦，我记得。我写了博客，现在我们
find out that Creed Bratton has a blog? Yes. Ryan explains in a talking head that last year, Creed asked him how to make a blog, but Ryan just opened up a word document and told him this was a blog. And he said that he did that in order to protect the world from Creed's thoughts. Yeah, because he said even for the internet, they're pretty scary. So then you see Creed working on his blog. And of course, you guys, I had to screen grab it and see what he wrote. So the top of his blog says www.credthoughts.gov. www. www. backslash creed thoughts. And this is what the screen says. Creed thoughts. Hey, oh, everyone out there in cyber world, cyber, spelled with an S. It's old, it's old Creed Bratton coming at you again. So we get to see his last name, which I love, Jenna.
发现克里德·布拉顿有一个博客？是的。瑞安在谈话环节解释说，去年，克里德问他如何制作博客，但瑞安只是打开了一个Word文档，告诉他这是一个博客。他说他这样做是为了保护世界免受克里德思想的影响。是的，因为他说即使对于互联网来说，它们也相当可怕。所以你看到克里德在写他的博客。当然，伙计们，我不得不截屏看看他写了什么。所以他的博客顶部写着www.credthoughts.gov。www. www. 反斜杠 creed thoughts。这就是屏幕上显示的内容。克里德思想。嘿，哦，网络世界里的每个人，网络，拼写为S。是老，是老克里德·布拉顿又来了。所以我们看到了他的姓氏，我喜欢，珍娜。
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yeah. So it says, It's Old Creed Broughton coming at you again, hear from my perch as a quality assurance manager at Dundermifflin paper. Just a few observations on the world around me. What do you guys think is the best kind of car? To me, you can't beat motorcycles. They're small and dangerous. I got into a car, and that's all you see. And I have to say this to Ryan, fictional character Ryan, I don't think that's so scary.
是的。是的。是的。是的。所以它写着，是老克里德·布拉顿又来了，从我在邓德米夫林纸业公司担任质量保证经理的职位上听到。关于我周围的世界的一些观察。你们觉得最好的车是什么？对我来说，摩托车是无与伦比的。它们又小又危险。我上了一辆车，这就是你所看到的全部。我必须对瑞安，虚构角色瑞安说，我不觉得那有那么可怕。
I'm like, why can't Creed blog about he, that he likes motorcycles? Well, there obviously is something that we're not seeing. I guess so. Well, we talked to Paul a little bit about this and he mentioned that Jason Kessler, our writer's assistant, actually did write for a little over a year, the blog of Creed Thoughts for NBC.com. And by the way, if you would like to look for it, you can still feel. find it. It is at blog.nbc.com backslash creed thoughts. I looked at it. There are so many amazing things. He has a whole story on there about how he stayed late one night at the office and he found a squirrel in Michael's safe. That's one of the stories. What? Yes. Yes. He says he's
我心想，为什么克里德不能写博客说他喜欢摩托车？好吧，显然有一些我们没有看到的东西。我想是这样。好吧，我们和保罗谈过这个，他提到杰森·凯斯勒，我们的编剧助理，实际上确实写了一年多，NBC.com的《克里德思想》博客。顺便说一句，如果你想找它，你仍然可以找到它。它在blog.nbc.com反斜杠 creed thoughts。我看过了。有很多令人惊奇的事情。他在上面有一个完整的故事，关于他有一天晚上在办公室待得很晚，他在迈克尔的保险箱里发现了一只松鼠。那是其中一个故事。什么？是的。是的。他说他
so glad that he figured out the combination of Michael's safe because it ended up saving a squirrel's life. He would like to know why Michael put a squirrel in his safe. That's one of his entries. Creed, did you really put it in there? And then you forgot about it? It's possible. It's possible. But you can check it out. It's still there. That's so fun. That's so fun. I didn't know it was still active. That's so fun. Well, now Michael visits the accounting department, and he's talking about his new job and how he's already sold his condo. And they're like, whoa, whoa, whoa. What's what? And I love this scene. I remembered when we were doing the scene, at the end of the scene, we improvised all of that. And when I was watching it, I was remembering that. And then I
很高兴他弄清楚了迈克尔保险箱的密码，因为它最终救了一只松鼠的命。他想知道为什么迈克尔把一只松鼠放在他的保险箱里。那是他的条目之一。克里德，你真的把它放在那里了吗？然后你忘了它？有可能。有可能。但你可以去看看。它还在那里。那太有趣了。那太有趣了。我不知道它还在运行。那太有趣了。好吧，现在迈克尔访问会计部，他在谈论他的新工作以及他已经卖掉了他的公寓。他们就像，哇，哇，哇。什么是什么？我喜欢这个场景。我记得当我们做这个场景时，在场景结束时，我们即兴发挥了所有这些。当我看着它时，我记得那个。然后我
went to the DVD commentary. And Ken Kwapis said, yeah, he was like, the scene didn't really have an ending. So I just asked the accountants if they would improvise sort of react. acting to Michael. And that's how we went out of the scene. I think this scene is such a great example of the three of you as an improvisational trio. You guys work so well off of one another. Your deliveries are spot on. And I noted it when I watched it, Angela, and I went to the script. And Ken Quapis is right. It really just ended with Michael giving the news that he's already sold his condo on eBay. That was the button. But I think this scene is brilliant because of your reaction. And I'm so glad they left it in. Well, I love that it made it in. And I really loved our little accounting pod. We so clearly knew
去了DVD评论。肯·夸皮斯说，是的，他说，这个场景并没有真正的结局。所以我只是问会计们他们是否会即兴发挥，对迈克尔做出反应。这就是我们走出场景的方式。我觉得这个场景是你们三个作为即兴三重奏的一个很好的例子。你们彼此配合得很好。你们的台词非常到位。当我观看它时，我注意到了，安吉拉，我去了剧本。肯·夸皮斯是对的。它真的只是以迈克尔宣布他已经在eBay上卖掉了他的公寓结束。那是按钮。但我认为这个场景之所以精彩是因为你们的反应。我很高兴他们把它留下了。好吧，我喜欢它被留下了。我真的很喜欢我们的小会计小组。我们非常清楚
our characters and how they would react to one another at all times. And we were rarely ever on the same page. But in this moment, all three of us have similar reactions. I say, who gave you that advice, you know? And then Kevin and Oscar all chime in. And for once, the accounting department is all on the same page. Well, we had a fan catch in this that I absolutely love from Adalia L. who said, you guys have mentioned that Phyllis was constantly looking at fences for her home. Please tell me she caught the fence on her computer. At about seven minutes, 20 seconds, I think she's looking at fences on her computer in the background of the scene. Angela, this is amazing.
我们的角色以及他们如何始终对彼此做出反应。我们很少在同一页上。但在这一刻，我们三个人都有类似的反应。我说，谁给了你那个建议，你知道吗？然后凯文和奥斯卡都插话了。会计部难得地在同一页上。好吧，我们在这个场景中有一个粉丝捕捉，我绝对喜欢，来自阿达利亚·L，她说，你们提到菲利斯一直在为她的家看栅栏。请告诉她她在电脑上看了栅栏。在大约7分20秒，我想她在场景背景的电脑上在看栅栏。安吉拉，这太神奇了。
Because you know how you were mentioning that sometimes you would check to see if you were in the background? Yeah. At 7 minutes, 10 seconds, Phyllis looks over her shoulder to accounting. And I swear that what she's doing is sneaking a look to see where the camera is. is. And I think she thinks she's not on camera because right after that, she clicks on a website to look at fences. Yes, that's exactly what she was doing. Yes, it was amazing. You guys, Phyllis looked at fences for like a year. Yeah. Like, like for months and months trying to, and we would, you know, she would want our opinion and we'd go over and we'd look at fences with her. Yeah. So many
因为你知道你是怎么提到有时你会检查你是否在背景中吗？是的。在7分10秒，菲利斯越过肩膀看向会计部。我发誓她正在做的是偷偷看摄像机在哪里。我想她认为她不在镜头里，因为在那之后，她点击了一个网站去看栅栏。是的，那正是她在做的。是的，太神奇了。伙计们，菲利斯看栅栏看了一年。是的。就像，几个月几个月地试图，我们会，你知道，她会想要我们的意见，我们会过去和她一起看栅栏。是的。这么多
It was great. So many fences. Well, now, Angela, speaking of scenes that I just absolutely love, this next one, with Dwight and Angela in the kitchen. And Dwight is telling Angela about his new promotion. He is going to have Michael's job. Oh, it's so good. It's so good. It's one of these Shakespearean moments between Dwight and Angela. Very Macbeth, right? And once again, they're not facing each other, you know. So Angela doesn't even see his face. And at the end, Angela, you say, goodbye, Kelly Kapoor. Oh, yeah. And that was not in the script, lady. I know, I know. So I got to improvise a little bit right there. And my memory is that I improvised that.
太棒了。这么多栅栏。好吧，现在，安吉拉，说到我绝对喜欢的场景，下一个，德怀特和安吉拉在厨房里。德怀特正在告诉安吉拉关于他的新晋升。他要得到迈克尔的工作。哦，太好了。太好了。这是德怀特和安吉拉之间这些莎士比亚式的时刻之一。非常麦克白，对吧？再一次，他们没有面对面，你知道。所以安吉拉甚至没有看到他的脸。最后，安吉拉，你说，再见，凯利·卡普尔。哦，是的。那不在剧本里，女士。我知道，我知道。所以我不得不即兴发挥了一点。我的记忆是，我即兴发挥了那个。
And when I listened to the DVD commentary, Dave Rogers said, I'm pretty sure Angela improvised that line. So I just figured she would just be consumed with her own power. And, you know, Dwight has said if he takes over, she gets to be in charge of the women. So it's sort of a callback. And, you know, Kelly Kapoor has been on her list for a long time. Well, I think this is also a callback to product recall. I think that Kelly went to the top of Angela's list after she had to sit through that customer service training.
当我听DVD评论时，戴夫·罗杰斯说，我很确定安吉拉即兴发挥了那句台词。所以我只是觉得她会被她自己的权力所消耗。而且，你知道，德怀特说过如果他接管，她就可以负责女性。所以这算是一种回调。而且，你知道，凯利·卡普尔已经在她的名单上很久了。好吧，我认为这也是对《产品召回》的回调。我认为凯利在不得不忍受那次客户服务培训后，排到了安吉拉名单的顶端。
Well, no doubt. No doubt. She tried to kiss Dwight at a Christmas party. And then there was Dawali and then product recall. also. Angela's like, see you later, Kelly Capua. Yeah. Who's next on Angela's list? The list is long, lady. The list is long. Is it Kevin? Maybe Kevin. Oh, for sure. For sure. And maybe she gets her way in the finale, just saying, okay, we're not there yet. Okay. Well, in the scene, Dwight and Angela have this really fun couplet of dialogue. Dwight says, how would you like to spend the night with a regional manager of Dundermifflin Scranton? And Angela goes, no, Dwight. And I don't care if that's how they consolidate. power in ancient Rome.
好吧，毫无疑问。毫无疑问。她在圣诞派对上试图亲吻德怀特。然后有排灯节，还有《产品召回》。安吉拉就像，回头见，凯利·卡普尔。是的。安吉拉名单上的下一个是谁？名单很长，女士。名单很长。是凯文吗？也许是凯文。哦，肯定的。肯定的。也许她在结局中如愿以偿，只是说，好吧，我们还没到那儿。好吧。好吧，在场景中，德怀特和安吉拉有这段非常有趣的对话。德怀特说，你想和邓德米夫林斯克兰顿的区域经理共度一夜吗？安吉拉说，不，德怀特。我不在乎这是否是他们在古罗马巩固权力的方式。
And he's like, I mean me. Well, listen, lady, I think maybe we should take a break. And when we come back, we're going to see what this new power does to Dwight. Oh, well, get ready. Get ready for his bed and breakfast in Hill. All right. We'll be right back. All right, we are back, and Dwight is taunting Jim about his new position at Hotel Hell.
他说，我是指我。好吧，听着，女士，我想也许我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将看看这种新权力对德怀特做了什么。哦，好吧，准备好。为他在地狱酒店的住宿加早餐做好准备。好的。我们马上回来。好的，我们回来了，德怀特正在嘲笑吉姆关于他在地狱酒店的新职位。
And he's doing one of those hand, what are they called? Those hand exercise are things. What are those for? Why am I exercising my hand? So your grip gets really strong. So I can hold heavier weights while I'm lifting weights. Is that what that's for? Or maybe.
他正在做那些手，它们叫什么？那些手部练习的东西。那些是干什么用的？为什么我在锻炼我的手？这样你的抓力会变得非常强。这样我在举重时可以拿更重的重量。那是为了那个吗？或者也许。
need a strong hand for. Maybe if you wrestle, you can grab someone and hold real tight. I don't know. I don't, I've never understood why I would want my hands to be super muscularly. Muscularly, muscular. I feel like, I feel like my husband has one and, um, I know, I know with baking like he's needing all kinds of dough and bread and doing stuff. And I feel like, I feel like he's got real strong hands. Oh, wow, do I need one of those? Maybe. So that I can need my dough better? Maybe. Then you'd have like super dough needing strength. Hmm. Anyway. Maybe I should ask for one for Christmas. Dwight is doing this throughout this whole ridiculous. I don't even know what it is. A dream or fantasy of his of this insane hotel hell. And then Jim just takes him to task so calmly. He's like, wait, wait. Wait.
需要一只强壮的手。也许如果你摔跤，你可以抓住某人并紧紧抓住。我不知道。我从来不明白为什么我想让我的手变得超级肌肉发达。肌肉发达，肌肉。我觉得，我觉得我丈夫有一个，嗯，我知道，我知道烘焙就像他在揉各种面团和面包，做事情。我觉得，我觉得他有非常强壮的手。哦，哇，我需要一个那样的吗？也许。这样我就可以更好地揉我的面团？也许。然后你就会有超级面团揉捏力量。嗯。不管怎样。也许我应该要求一个作为圣诞礼物。德怀特在整个这个荒谬的过程中都在做这个。我甚至不知道那是什么。他的一个梦或幻想，关于这个疯狂的地狱酒店。然后吉姆只是冷静地让他承担任务。他说，等等，等等。
you're the manager you don't this is your fantasy you don't even own it and he's like I go own it with Satan yeah and he's like I just want to make sure I'm clear that your wildest fantasy has you as the co-owner of a bed and breakfast with Satan in hell and but you only make $80,000 a year oh yeah Dwight's like wait wait I haven't told you the best part yeah best part I make $80,000 a year now Jenna so here's a thing I I saw on line that fans at the office were like, you know, if you divide 80,000 by 12, you get like 6666.666.6.67 or something like that. And I was like, oh, my God, do the writers do that on purpose? They must have. They had to us. They must have. Well, what a brilliant little layer they gave that then.
你是经理，你没有，这是你的幻想，你甚至不拥有它，他说，我和撒旦一起拥有它。是的，他说，我只是想确保我清楚，你最狂野的幻想是你和撒旦在地狱里共同拥有一个住宿加早餐旅馆，但你一年只赚8万美元。哦，是的，德怀特就像，等等，等等，我还没告诉你最好的部分。是的，最好的部分，我现在一年赚8万美元，珍娜。所以这里有一件事，我在网上看到《办公室》的粉丝们说，你知道，如果你用8万除以12，你会得到像6666.666.6.67之类的东西。我心想，哦，天哪，编剧们是故意那样做的吗？他们一定是。他们必须。他们一定是。好吧，他们给那个层级赋予了多么精彩的小层级啊。
We had a lot of people write in about that. Rebecca Walmack, Beth Jones, and Paulina J. and Jake Moss all also noticed that $80,000 a year is $6,666.66. That's pretty cool. I mean, that's a little, I mean, I like little details like that. I think that's fun. You know, if that were my salary, I think I would be a little bit weirded out. I don't think I would want to have a salary. I wouldn't want to get checks.
我们有很多人写信谈论那个。丽贝卡·沃尔马克、贝丝·琼斯和保琳娜·J和杰克·莫斯也都注意到一年8万美元是6666.66美元。那很酷。我的意思是，那有点，我的意思是，我喜欢像那样的小细节。我觉得那很有趣。你知道，如果那是我的薪水，我想我会有点被吓到。我不认为我想有那样的薪水。我不想收到支票。
I mean, I guess you take out the taxes and everything, your check wouldn't really say that. But even still in my mind, I think it would weird me out. because do you know what I had for a very long time? What? I had a credit card and you know you have your little three digit secret code. My secret code was 666. Oh, no, no. No, I'd say get that away.
我的意思是，我想你扣除税收和一切，你的支票不会真的那样写。但即使在我的脑海里，我想它也会让我感到奇怪。因为你知道我有一段时间有什么吗？什么？我有一张信用卡，你知道你有你的小三位数秘密代码。我的秘密代码是666。哦，不，不。不，我会说把它拿走。
Uh-uh. I'm not having any of that. I would be on the phone trying to buy something. Like, let's say I'm ordering a pizza and they'd be like, what's your credit card number? And they'd be like, and the security code? And I would always be like, it's 666.6.6. And what would they say? People would be like, what? They would laugh. And I'd always have to be like, I know. I know. And I wanted to like just intentionally get rid of this card so they would issue me a new one. Now that's not my security code anymore. But I imagine that's like layered because it's like on the one hand, that's creepy. It's creepy. And then. you have to say these creepy numbers. But then you also now have chitty chat. When you just want to order your pizza, now that person's hearing it for the first time. So they're like, oh my God,
呃-呃。我不会有任何那种东西。我会打电话试图买东西。比如，假设我正在订披萨，他们会说，你的信用卡号码是多少？他们会说，安全码呢？我总是会说，它是666.6.6。他们会说什么？人们会说，什么？他们会笑。我总是不得不说，我知道。我知道。我想故意摆脱这张卡，这样他们就会给我发一张新的。现在那不再是我的安全码了。但我认为这就像分层，因为它一方面，那很令人毛骨悚然。它很令人毛骨悚然。然后。你必须说这些令人毛骨悚然的数字。但你现在也有闲聊。当你只是想订披萨时，现在那个人是第一次听到它。所以他们就像，哦，天哪，
that's weird. Yeah, I know. Oh, are you going to change it? I'm going to try. But like over and over for two years. For two years. Well, then Dwight has a talking head. He says his first order of business will be to demote Jim, which means he will need a new number two. His first choice would be Jack Bauer. You know, from 24, but he's fictional and unavailable. This was a nod to Ricky Jervase and Stephen Merchant. How so? They loved 24. Love 24.
那很奇怪。是的，我知道。哦，你要改吗？我会试一试。但就像一遍又一遍，两年了。两年了。好吧，然后德怀特有一个谈话环节。他说他的第一项业务将是降职吉姆，这意味着他将需要一个新的二号人物。他的第一选择是杰克·鲍尔。你知道，来自《24小时》，但他是一个虚构人物，而且不可用。这是对瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫昌特的致敬。怎么说？他们喜欢《24小时》。喜欢《24小时》。
They were obsessed with it. They both got cameos on 24. I went, yes, and I watched them. So, Ricky Jervais was in the sixth season. His scene did not make it, but you can find it online, and I guess it's on like the DVD box set or something. and he's having this comedic moment in the Oval Office. It's totally random because, you know, 24 is such a drama.
他们对它着迷。他们俩都在《24小时》中客串。我去了，是的，我看了他们。所以，瑞奇·热维斯在第六季。他的场景没有成功，但你可以在网上找到它，我想它在DVD盒装里或其他什么地方。他正在椭圆形办公室里进行这个喜剧时刻。这完全是随机的，因为，你知道，《24小时》是一部如此戏剧性的剧。
The stakes are so high. But he's in the background with his longtime girlfriend, Jane Fallon. They got to be in the show. And then later on, Stephen Merchant makes a brief appearance. He doesn't have a speaking role, but he's a C.T.U worker. He wasn't credited on the episode, but he is there. He's in the background when they cut to C.T.U. So he made it in.
赌注太高了。但他和他的长期女友简·法伦在背景中。他们有机会出现在节目中。然后后来，斯蒂芬·莫昌特短暂露面。他没有说话的角色，但他是一个C.T.U工作人员。他在那一集中没有被列入演职员表，但他确实在那里。当他们切到C.T.U时，他在背景中。所以他成功了。
He made the cut. He has no lines, but he made it in. But I guess this little reference to Jack Bauer from Dwight was a little nod to Ricky and Stephen from the writers. I love that. Well, now something major happens. Two major things happen. Jan shows up at the office unannounced. And we talked about this scene a little bit with Paul, where Jan and Michael are standing at reception with Pam between them.
他成功了。他没有台词，但他成功了。但我猜德怀特对杰克·鲍尔的这个小参考是编剧对瑞奇和斯蒂芬的一点致敬。我喜欢这一点。好吧，现在发生了一件大事。发生了两件大事。简不请自来地出现在办公室。我们和保罗谈过这个场景，简和迈克尔站在接待处，帕姆在他们中间。
And Michael is trying so hard to have boundaries. Oh, I loved it when she walked in and he goes, why are you here? And Malora is being that very, very scary, sane version of a crazy person. Oh, no, for sure. Like in the horror movies right before they turn on you. Yeah, no, it's that moment where you're like, hi, lovely. And then it's like, ha! Yes, like you're wondering, wait, are they a cyborg?
迈克尔正努力地划清界限。噢，她走进来时他说“你为什么在这儿？”我太喜欢这一幕了。梅洛拉演出了那种非常、非常可怕，但又看起来很理智的疯狂。噢，没错。就像恐怖电影里，他们在对你下手之前的那一刻。是的，就是那种你觉得“嗨，亲爱的”，然后突然“哈！”的感觉。没错，就像你在想，等等，她是机器人吗？
Yeah. I made you coffee, honey. With the knife. Yes. Yes. Yes. Super creepy. She goes into his office and Michael is like, I need all my ladies.
是的。我给你煮了咖啡，亲爱的。用刀煮的。是的。是的。是的。超级诡异。她走进他的办公室，迈克尔说，我需要我所有的女士们。
Def content. In the conference room. Def content, Pam. Immediately. Except Meredith, who's an alternate. Yeah. Well, so now Pam has to go tell everybody, right? So she goes up to Karen and she's like, hey, Michael needs us.
进入戒备状态。在会议室里。进入戒备状态，帕姆。立刻。除了梅雷迪思，她是候补。是的。好吧，现在帕姆得去告诉大家，对吧？所以她走到凯伦面前说，嘿，迈克尔需要我们。
Jan's here. He's freaking out. And Karen is so passive-aggressive in this moment. She's like, okay, listen, before we leave, would you make, you know, copies of our sales reports? Would you go make some copies? Would you photocopy some stuff for me? Oh, and for my boyfriend, whom I'm about to go to New York with for the night? Will you make us some photocopies?
简来了。他快疯了。凯伦此刻表现得非常消极怠工。她说，好吧，听着，在我们离开之前，你能帮我复印一下销售报告吗？你能去复印一下吗？能帮我复印些东西吗？噢，还有，为了我那个马上要一起去纽约过夜的男朋友？你能帮我们复印一下吗？
That's the subtext. Yeah. I know. I'm just going to take a minute and I'm going to put you in your place, Miss receptionist. Yeah, she does. It's true. And then, though, Pam, Pam, leaning hard into this new, like,
这就是潜台词。是的。我知道。我得花点时间让你认清自己的位置，接待员小姐。是的，她确实这么做了。是真的。但是，帕姆，帕姆，开始坚定地展现她新的一面，
I'm going to say stuff when I want to say it, looks right at her and goes, I hope you get the job. Yeah. Little Pam's ass. I want your ass out of here. I'll make your copies. I want your ass gone.
我想说什么就说什么，她直视着她说，我希望你能得到那份工作。是的。小帕姆真带劲。我希望你赶紧滚蛋。我会帮你复印的。我希望你赶紧消失。
I'll make you 12 copies. How about that? You can shove them where the sun don't shine. Okay. So Jan explains to Michael. She gives her plea. She says that after their breakup, she went on vacation. Another vacation.
我会帮你复印12份。怎么样？你可以把它们塞进见不得光的地方。好吧。所以简向迈克尔解释。她进行了恳求。她说分手后她去度假了。又去度假了。
Yeah. But she's made some big changes and she really, really misses him and she wants to get back together. Michael runs out of the office and into the conference room. DefCon 20. And all the women in the conference room are like, Michael, no, do not get back together with her. You have to stay strong. She doesn't make you happy. We are good.
是的。但她做了一些重大改变，她真的、真的很想他，想和他复合。迈克尔冲出办公室跑进会议室。进入20级戒备状态。会议室里的所有女性都说，迈克尔，不，不要和她复合。你必须保持坚定。她让你不快乐。我们很好。
We all agree. Mm-hmm. Michael's like, yes. Yeah. So now he feels empowered. He's going to go in and tell Jan no. No. Yeah.
我们都同意。嗯哼。迈克尔说，是的。是的。所以现在他感到充满力量。他要进去告诉简“不”。不。是的。
We are not getting back together. But he walks back in his office and Jan has taken off her jacket to reveal that she has had breast augmentation surgery. She is wearing a white, very tight little knit sweater with a plunging neckline. Yep. And she's got a bodacious. said tattas. She does. That are like, hello, in his eyes.
我们不会复合的。但他走回办公室，简脱掉了外套，露出她做了隆胸手术。她穿着一件白色的、非常紧身的小针织衫，领口开得很低。没错。她有一对波涛汹涌的……胸部。她确实有。就像在对他的眼睛说“你好”。
He walks in and he's like, what? My gosh. Because he's such an adolescent. He cannot take his eyes off her chest. And she knows it. This is going to appeal to Michael. Absolutely. Absolutely.
他走进去说，什么？天哪。因为他就像个青春期少年。他的眼睛无法从她的胸部移开。而她知道这一点。这会吸引迈克尔。绝对会。绝对会。
She knew what she was doing. Well, we had some people ask, did Malora get a breast augmentation for this episode? No, no, she didn't. They designed this crazy bra for her that was filled with like a gazillion little cutlets. And then they did this like makeup shadowing on her chest to create even more illusion of like swollen cleavage and all of that. And I do remember poor Melora from this point forward would have to put that on for every episode now. I listened to the DVD commentary and Ken Koppop.
她知道自己在做什么。嗯，有人问，梅洛拉是为了这一集去做了隆胸手术吗？不，不，她没有。他们为她设计了一个疯狂的胸罩，里面塞满了无数的小垫子。然后他们在她的胸部做了化妆阴影，制造出一种更加肿胀的乳沟错觉。我记得从那时起，可怜的梅洛拉每一集都得戴上那个。我听了DVD评论音轨，肯·卡帕
and Malora were part of this commentary. And they said they had a meeting to discuss her boob job storyline with Greg. So it was Ken Malora and Greg. And they really had a like earnest conversation about what size they would be. Like how big would Jan go? And how much of a visual joke would this be? And Malora said this whole storyline was just a lot of fun. It was just a really fun thing for her character and just part of that journey that Paul was talking about of Jan really starting this spiral. And she did say that for a long time, people would come up to her and ask if those boobs were hers. Oh, I know. Poor Malora. Poor Malora. Oh, my gosh. Well, it works. Michael gets back together with Jan. He says it's not for the boobs.
和梅洛拉参与了评论。他们说他们和格雷格开会讨论了她的隆胸剧情。所以是肯、梅洛拉和格雷格。他们真的很认真地讨论了尺寸问题。比如简会做多大？这会是一个多大的视觉笑话？梅洛拉说整个剧情非常有趣。这对她的角色来说是一件非常有趣的事情，也是保罗所说的简开始螺旋式失控旅程的一部分。她确实说过，很长一段时间里，人们都会走过来问她那些胸部是不是真的。噢，我知道。可怜的梅洛拉。可怜的梅洛拉。天哪。嗯，这招奏效了。迈克尔和简复合了。他说这不是因为胸部。
It wasn't for the boobs. No. Of course not. But he's so... He said that would be shallow. And this is actually emotionally magnificent. Yeah. So, yeah, he's going to give this relationship another try.
不是因为胸部。不。当然不是。但他太……他说那太肤浅了。而这实际上在情感上是宏大的。是的。所以，是的，他要再试一次这段关系。
Yeah. Well, Jan walks out into the bullpen. Oh, by the way, I can't believe I forgot to bring this up. In the very beginning when she shows up, Michael goes, Janet. And I was like, what? I forgot. Her name was Janet. It is?
是的。嗯，简走到办公区。噢，顺便说一下，我真不敢相信我忘了提这个。在最开始她出现的时候，迈克尔说，珍妮特。我当时想，什么？我忘了。她的名字是珍妮特。是吗？
Yes. when she enters the office and I'm sorry to take us back a minute, he says, hello, Janet. And I'm like, Janet, that's my sister's name. But is that just Michael doing Michael? No, no, I looked it up. Her character's name is Janet, and her nickname is Jan. Wow. Yes.
是的。当她进入办公室时，抱歉打断一下，他说，你好，珍妮特。我当时想，珍妮特，那是我姐姐的名字。但这只是迈克尔在犯傻吗？不，不，我查过了。她角色的名字是珍妮特，昵称是简。哇。是的。
Wow. Mm-hmm. There you go. Janet Levinson, gold. Drop the gold. She's not with gold anymore. And so she walks into the bullpen and now everyone sees her new boobs and everyone is having their reactions. You know, Meredith is like, waste of money.
哇。嗯哼。就是这样。珍妮特·莱文森，金。去掉了金。她不再和金在一起了。所以她走进办公区，现在每个人都看到了她的新胸部，每个人都有各自的反应。你知道，梅雷迪思说，浪费钱。
I find that guys are way more interested in the back of you than the front and her experience. And I thought Kate did such a great job with that talking head. She just throws that line away. She doesn't put too much on it. Yeah. And she did a brilliant job. And Pam, once again, try. trying to flirt with Jim. It's like, oh my God, they're so big. And he's like, I know. She's just trying to flirt. She's trying to flirt. She wants to be friends again. She's being friendly. She wants to be friends with benefits. Well, she wants to be more than friends. Yeah. While everyone is reacting to the boobs, we have another pretty big storyline, which is Dwight is going to start interviewing his new number two. And the only person who signed up was Andy. Yes. Which leads to this amazing interview.
我发现男人们对你的背面比正面更感兴趣，这是她的经验。我觉得凯特在那个采访镜头里表现得太棒了。她只是随口一说。她没有刻意强调。是的。她做得非常出色。而帕姆，再一次，试图和吉姆调情。就像，噢天哪，它们太大了。他说，我知道。她只是在试图调情。她是在试图调情。她想再次成为朋友。她表现得很友好。她想成为“有福利的朋友”。嗯，她想成为不仅仅是朋友的关系。是的。当每个人都在对胸部做出反应时，我们还有另一个相当大的剧情，那就是德怀特要开始面试他的新二把手。唯一报名的人是安迪。是的。这导致了这场精彩的面试。
scene between Dwight and Andy. It's like a rapid fire Q&A session. And it's so great. We had a fan question from Seth Jason Tan and Zhu Yi Wang. How much of the dialogue between Andy and Dwight was scripted when Dwight is interviewing him for assistant to the regional manager? Well, guys, everything you see in the episode was scripted, but there was so much more in the script. Angela, is that stuff? in the deleted scenes because it was so funny on the page. There are great deleted scenes, Jenna, from this scene. And apparently there's even more that we're not even getting to see on the DVDs. I listened to the DVD commentary and they said these guys went on and on and on. And then
德怀特和安迪之间的场景。就像一场快速问答环节。太棒了。我们收到了来自塞斯·杰森·谭和朱毅王（音译）的粉丝提问。当德怀特面试安迪担任助理区域经理时，安迪和德怀特之间的对话有多少是剧本写的？嗯，伙计们，你们在剧集中看到的一切都是剧本写的，但剧本里还有更多内容。安吉拉，那些东西在删减片段里吗？因为在纸面上太搞笑了。珍娜，这一幕有很棒的删减片段。显然还有更多我们甚至在DVD上都看不到的内容。我听了DVD评论音轨，他们说这些人没完没了地演。然后
they went past the scripted stuff and they just started improvising. And Ken Kwappa said rain was just throwing the craziest stuff at Ed and Ed did not miss a beat. Like, like, all right, walk me through an appendectomy. And Ed is Andy is like, all right, you sterilize the area. You make an incision. You know, he just, you know, did this whole thing. They're great deleted scenes on the DVD, but I think there's even more that we don't get to see. It was amazing.
他们超出了剧本内容，开始即兴发挥。肯·卡帕说雷恩只是在向艾德抛出最疯狂的东西，而艾德完全接住了。比如，好吧，演示一下阑尾切除术。艾德饰演的安迪说，好吧，你对区域进行消毒。你做一个切口。你知道，他只是做了整套动作。DVD上有很棒的删减片段，但我认为还有更多我们看不到的内容。太神奇了。
I absolutely loved it. And Dwight has no choice. This is his only choice. Yeah. Which is so great. Well, we're going to end this part one of the job with Michael finally leaving for his interview. He is holding Jan's breasts. Well, they've shut the blinds, but they've only shut them on one side of his office.
我绝对喜欢它。德怀特别无选择。这是他唯一的选择。是的。这太棒了。好吧，我们要结束这一集“工作”的第一部分，迈克尔终于要去面试了。他正抓着简的胸部。嗯，他们拉上了百叶窗，但只拉上了他办公室的一侧。
They left him open on the other side. And so the camera gets this little, I used to call it a peep shot. That's not what it's called. Sneaky shot. Spy view. Sneak, spy shot. You got it. You got there.
他们留下了另一侧没拉。所以摄像机拍到了这个小镜头，我过去称之为“偷窥镜头”。那不是它的名字。鬼祟镜头。间谍视角。鬼祟，间谍镜头。你答对了。你做到了。
Spy shot. You found it. I got there. Thanks for sticking with me. Michael's just cupping them. He's just holding them. He's like so happy. Just holding them in his hands.
间谍镜头。你找到了。我做到了。谢谢你一直陪着我。迈克尔只是捧着它们。他只是抓着它们。他看起来太开心了。只是把它们捧在手里。
And then he has this crazy talking head where he says two weeks ago he was in the worst relationship of his life. And now he's in the best relationship of his life with the same woman. Isn't love a mystery? Angela, I mean, can you get a breast augmentation and heal from it in only two weeks? Is that enough time? I know. I thought she was gone longer, too.
然后他有一个疯狂的采访镜头，他说两周前他处于人生中最糟糕的关系中。现在他和同一个女人处于人生中最好的关系中。爱情难道不是个谜吗？安吉拉，我的意思是，你可以做隆胸手术并在短短两周内恢复吗？那是足够的时间吗？我知道。我也以为她离开的时间更长。
It seemed like to me they hadn't been dating for quite some time. I thought there was a bigger passage of time. I do too, because when he walks over to accounting, he's like, I haven't talked to Jan ages, right? Well, I know that women's appreciation was two episodes ago, but I thought there was more time in real life that had passed. So that bumped me when he said two weeks. I was like, wait, what? And also like, I just would think her boobs would still be so sore. I mean, I don't know. Should I look it up? I think this was maybe a continuity error in writing, but I think he said a longer passage of time when he went to accounting?
在我看来，他们好像已经很久没约会了。我以为时间跨度更大。我也这么认为，因为当他走到会计部时，他说，我很久没和简说话了，对吧？嗯，我知道“女性鉴赏日”是两集之前的事，但我以为现实生活中已经过去了更长时间。所以当他说两周时，我感到很惊讶。我当时想，等等，什么？而且，我觉得她的胸部应该还会很疼。嗯，我不知道。我应该查一下吗？我觉得这可能是剧本里的连续性错误，但我记得他在会计部时说的时间跨度更长？
Well, according to Plastic Surgery.org Yeah. Most surgeons agree that full recovery can take an average of six weeks or so, but that many women notice they feel fine after about only one week. So there you go.
嗯，根据Plastic Surgery.org的说法，是的。大多数外科医生同意完全恢复平均需要六周左右，但许多女性注意到她们在大约一周后就感觉不错了。所以，就是这样。
But I still think this is a continuity error because of what he said in accounting. I think so too. Well, Michael goes to Pam and he says, Pam, you gave me great advice, but Jan's was bigger. Yeah, Jan's advice was bigger. So Michael's going to say his goodbyes.
但我仍然认为这是一个连续性错误，因为他在会计部说的话。我也这么认为。好吧，迈克尔走到帕姆身边说，帕姆，你给了我很好的建议，但简的建议更大。是的，简的建议更大。所以迈克尔要告别了。
You know, he really believes that he's leaving for the very last time. He believes he's going to go to this interview and get a job at corporate, and he and Jan are going to live happily ever after. He sold his condo. The man is leaving in his mind. He plays exit music, and he bids everybody a good night. and a good luck. Yes, he plays Natalie Merchant on a tiny little tape recorder.
你知道，他真的相信这是他最后一次离开。他相信他要去参加面试并得到一份公司的工作，他和简将从此过上幸福的生活。他卖掉了他的公寓。在他心里，这个人要走了。他播放了离别音乐，并祝大家晚安，祝大家好运。是的，他用一个小录音机播放了娜塔莉·莫昌特的歌。
And after he leaves, Dwight slaps his name on the door and says who's ready to work. And guess who's smiling? Oh, she's so happy. This is a big moment for them. This is a big moment. Well, we will end there for this week. Next week, we will keep breaking down this episode. Jim, Karen, and Michael will all arrive in New York for their interviews.
在他离开后，德怀特把他的名字贴在门上，说谁准备好工作了。猜猜谁在笑？噢，她太开心了。这对他们来说是一个重要的时刻。这是一个重要的时刻。好吧，我们本周就到这里。下周，我们将继续拆解这一集。吉姆、凯伦和迈克尔都将抵达纽约参加面试。
Dwight fully takes over Dunder Mifflin with Pam as his secret assistant to the regional manager. Oh, yeah. That's all next week. Oh, yeah. It's a good one, guys. Thank you so much for listening in. And thank you, Paul Lieberstein, for being our guest. We will see you next week with Job Number Two.
德怀特完全接管了邓德·米夫林，帕姆担任他秘密的助理区域经理。噢，是的。那都是下周的内容。噢，是的。这集很棒，伙计们。非常感谢你们的收听。也感谢保罗·利伯斯坦作为我们的嘉宾。我们下周见，继续“工作”第二部分。
It's a date. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jirkins, and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
一言为定。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯酒》。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·吉尔金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。
We want to talk to you guys a little bit about new ego protein waffles. It's really good. Tastes great. Plus, it's going to give you 20% of your daily protein. Yes, ego protein plus waffles provide the same great taste of ego that you know and love, plus 10 grams of protein per serving. I made the new eggo protein waffles for my kids the other day. they didn't even know that they were protein waffles.
我们想和你们聊聊新的Ego蛋白华夫饼。真的很好吃。味道很棒。而且，它能为你提供每日所需蛋白质的20%。是的，Ego蛋白加华夫饼提供了你所熟知和喜爱的Ego的美味，每份含有10克蛋白质。前几天我给我的孩子们做了新的Ego蛋白华夫饼。他们甚至不知道那是蛋白华夫饼。
They're just the ego waffles that you know and love. I know they have protein. They're just yummy waffles. Yes. I mean, listen, I know we're talking about breakfast, but I have shared this before. I like them as an afternoon treat. And when your teenagers come home hungry, guess what's real easy to give them? A little protein waffle.
它们就是你所熟知和喜爱的Ego华夫饼。我知道它们含有蛋白质。它们只是美味的华夫饼。是的。我的意思是，听着，我知道我们在谈论早餐，但我之前分享过。我喜欢把它们当作下午的点心。当你的青少年放学回家感到饥饿时，猜猜给他们什么最容易？一个小蛋白华夫饼。
They say you can fuel your morning, but you can also fuel your afternoon. Sure can. Head to your local grocery store to fuel your morning with ego protein waffles and pancakes available at retailers nationwide. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们说你可以为你的早晨补充能量，但你也可以为你的下午补充能量。当然可以。前往你当地的杂货店，用在全国零售商处有售的Ego蛋白华夫饼和煎饼为你的早晨补充能量。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。